So, da bin ich, ich bin schon ungefähr eine Stunde, bisschen länger, irgendwie so eine
Stunde wach, aber wirklich wach bin ich immer noch nicht, ich habe, sag mal so, ich habe
die Augen auf seit einer Stunde. Jetzt habe ich irgendwas im Auge. Ja, ich weiß nicht,
ob jemand von euch, der schon da ist, gestern im Stream dabei war, ich habe mich nach dem
Stream gestern noch etwas mit dem Thema beschäftigt und das ist ein Fass ohne Boden, also das
automatische Systeme in der Cloud erzeugen, da gibt es ja wirklich 30.000 Tools, was man
da alles noch für verwenden kann. Wir sind eindeutig noch nicht Cloud-Native genug hier
im Stream. Da müssen wir noch ein paar Streams machen und uns damit auseinandersetzen. So.
Und Chat, was gibt es bei euch? Neues. Irgendwas Spannendes. Äh, ich habe, gestern haben wir
was geschrieben mit Herznam. Also, ich denke, weil es gibt bald einen neuen Code und wieder
ein paar Sponsor-Streams. Gestern Abend habe ich mit meinem Manager was überlegt, was wir
machen. Und wir fangen wahrscheinlich an mit einem Sponsor-Stream über neue Herznam-Features,
das sie vor ein paar Wochen eingeführt haben bzw. noch einführen werden.
So. Alles Cloud. Mit echten, mit echter Hardware habe ich da nichts vorzumachen, das sei denn,
die wollen das und mache ich das auch. Aber alles hauptsächlich, also eigentlich alles
Cloud-Zeug.
Ne. Ich bin nicht krank. Also nicht mehr als sonst.
Na ja.
Na ja, ich bin schon, wie gesagt, ich bin seit über einer Stunde schon wach. Also augenoffen.
Aber nicht wirklich wach.
Ich muss euch was erzählen, fällt mir gerade ein. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich jetzt drauf
komme, aber wir haben gestern so viele Cloud-Server neu aufgebaut, gelöscht neuerdings. Ich habe
heute Nacht geträumt vom Cloud-Server provisionen. Kein Spaß, wisst ihr. Da muss schon irgendwas
echt, muss mich mitgenommen haben gestern. Und zwar, ich hab geträumt, ich musste, es
ergibt zwar, ok, ich gebe zu, es ergibt wenig Sinn, aber wann ergibt sowas schon Sinn?
Ich hab geträumt, ich musste auf einem U-Boot, auf einem U-Boot, irgendwelche Cloud-Server
einrichten, möglichst schnell, weil sonst irgendwas Schlimmes passiert wäre. Ich hab
keine Ahnung. Es ergibt zwar keinen Sinn, warum ich Cloud-Server in einem U-Boot einrichten
muss, aber gut.
Und es waren, also es waren alle, ich weiß auch, es war allen klar, es waren Cloud-Server.
Das Problem ist nur, die Server standen im U-Boot. Das war keine Cloud-Server, aber
es ist egal. Das haben alle was geredet von, ich muss Cloud-Server einrichten und zwar
ganz schnell. Und die Server standen da halt rum, im U-Boot, wohlgemerkt. Keine Ahnung.
Es ergibt nicht unbedingt Sinn. Cloud-Server Provision im U-Boot, dass es nicht untergeht.
Ich hab, ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das, es musste schnell sein, die haben alle übel
Sparling, es musste übel schnell provisioniert werden. Ja, gut, wenn man gestern vier Stunden
in einem Cloud-Server löscht und erstellt und löscht und erstellt und irgendwann geht
das ins Unterbewusstsein über. Doch es gibt, oder es gab, es gab ein Unterwasser-RZ von
Microsoft. Ich glaube, das haben die aber wieder. Das war irgendwie for Scotland oder so? Ja,
einen Moment, die hatten noch mal eins. Oder ist das das? Orkney-Insel. Moment, wo sind,
doch, Scotland, sag ich doch. Sag ich doch, irgendwo vor Schottland in der Küste war
das. Ja. Ich glaube, es hat wirklich, es hat nicht so großartig was gebracht, weil das
hat sich nicht, nicht durchgesetzt. Ich glaube, eines der blödesten Dinger an einem Unterwasser-Rechenzentrum
ist, du kannst halt nicht mal rein nebenbei. Das muss wirklich komplett autonom laufen
und egal was ist, du kannst halt nicht hochziehen, ja. Du könntest halt vielleicht, wenn du
davon mehrere hast, dann wird es wieder gehen. Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt dann irgendwie
30 davon und es wird halt quasi, oder sag mal so, am besten wäre natürlich, ihr habt
davon irgendwie 150 oder so und jeden Tag, oder jeden Tag wird irgendwie eins für zwei
Tage hochgekurbelt und alles gefixt und wieder runtergekurbelt. Das wäre natürlich kein
Sinn, aber ich glaube, das ist deutlich zu aufwendig. Dann bräuchte es ja quasi so ein
komplettes Kransystem und so. Also, das ist glaube ich was, was auf dem Papier gut aussieht,
aber in der Praxis dann doch nicht so gut funktioniert hat, wie sie es hier machen,
weil sonst hätte man das wahrscheinlich regelmäßig gemacht. Leia, die sagen, du hast den Vorteil,
dass du keine extra Kühlung brauchst, dass du keine, dass du irgendwie Strom vor Ort
generieren kannst und gedönst, ja. Von der Idee her ist es sicherlich nicht schlecht,
aber ich glaube, dass es in der Praxis, aber deswegen finde ich es ganz gut, wenn sowas
ausprobiert wird. Aber ich glaube halt, in der Praxis hat es doch mehr Probleme, als
es auf den ersten Blick aussehen mag. Sowas wäre noch was. Holt Stack, warum soll ich
virtuelle Desktops? Arbeitest du da? Machst du gerade Werbung für dir? Was? Ne, das kenne
ich nicht, aber warum soll ich Desktops in der Cloud? Ich meine, wenn ich in der Cloud
eine Arbeitsumgebung brauche, dann nehme ich Codespaces oder sowas und ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass die Linux Kisten gar nicht ordentlich funktionieren, weil Linux Remote
Desktop ist sowas, das ist eklig. X-Forwarding kannst du nicht machen, das ist Müll. VNC
ist auch Müll. RDP in der Variante, wie es unter Linux unterstützt, ist auch Müll.
Man bräuchte sowas wie RDP mit den 3D Extensions. Die haben seit ein paar Versionen RDP, 3D
Beschleunigung und generell GPU-Beschleunigung. Du kannst dann theoretisch teilweise auch sogar
GPU-Features von der Host-GPU in der VM benutzen. Das ist schon ganz cool, aber das geht unter
Linux alles nicht. Also Desktop-Virtualisierung, Remote unter Linux, naja, wenn das so einfach
wäre, hätte ich meine VM nicht. Wenn das so einfach wäre, hätte ich auf irgendeiner
fetten Server-Kiste hier hinter mir eine Linux-VM. Ja, ist echt so, also alles, was man versucht
mit GPU-Unterstützung ist. Das Einzige, was unter Linux halbwegs funktioniert, sind Intel-GPUs,
aber es fehlt halt auch alles drum herum. Und selbst da, weiss ich, ob Quick Sync mittlerweile
gescheit funktioniert. Das hier, das ist Windows und da drin habe ich dann einfach meine Linux-VM
im Vollbild. Guck, sieht dann so aus. Ich habe das hier im Vollbild und dann kann ich
hin und her switchen. Das Schöne ist, dass Windows, das ist für mich im Nachhinein die
beste Neuerung seit Ewigkeiten für Windows gewesen, dass die endlich virtuelle Desktops
haben. Dass du zwischen mehreren Desktops umschalten kannst hier. Das ist alles, das
ging vorher auch, aber sehr hacky nur mit Zusatzsoftware, die dann eigentlich nichts
anderes gemacht hat, wie Fenster unmappt und Fenster reingemapped. Ich gehe davon aus,
die Schiebe-Animation ist für Windows. Ich gehe davon aus, dass Windows das genauso
macht, dass Windows eigentlich auch nur, weil man sieht es wieder reinploppen, guckt wenn
ich auf dem Desktop bin und hier rum schalte, dann ploppen die Dinge erst wieder rein. Also
ich denke tatsächlich, dass das auch nur Fenster sichtbar mappt und unmappt. Das ist ja das,
was im Prinzip hier unter Windows i3 auch macht, wenn ich Desktops durchschalte. Die
unmappen einfach nur Fenster und mappen sie wieder sichtbar, aber es ist halt schöner
in Windows integriert und nicht so hakelig wie bei der Softwarelösung vor Windows 10.
Also das ist für mich, nee das gibt es erst, echt, nee das gibt es erst seit Windows 10.
Ich weiß noch, ich habe damals ein Windows 10 Preview Video gemacht und da war ich ganz
begeistert über Windows 10 Desktops. Vielleicht gab es das in der Windows 8.1 auch, kann sein,
unter Windows 8.1 hatte ich nie. Was ist deiner Meinung nach die beste Art programmieren
zu lernen? Das erste ist, du musst dir überlegen, welche Richtung, also was du vorhast. Willst
du Webseiten machen, willst du irgendwelche Machine Learning Sachen machen oder willst
du irgendwelche Science, Mathe Sachen machen? Also das einfachste, wenn du keine Ahnung
hast, weißt du, das einfachste ist, mit was du anfangen kannst, nimm dir einen Texteditor,
nicht ein Notepad, also irgendwas, nimm dir Visual Studio Code, koste nichts und mach
bisschen HTML und Javascript. Ich wimm, als Wimm als Einstieg Leute. Willst du, dass die
Leute das nie wieder anfassen oder wie? Nimm deinen Browser, nimm einen ordentlichen Texteditor
wie Visual Studio Code und lern Javascript Basics. Nicht Notepad++, Visual Studio Code
für Frontend Sachen. Ja, die neuen kommen auch aus Wim nicht mehr raus, das stimmt.
Ich meine, mir fallen aus vier verschiedene Sachen ein Wim zu exiten. Warum es da auch
immer vier verschiedene gibt? Es gibt nicht nur mir, es gibt wahrscheinlich 80 verschiedene
oder so. So, also ich würde Visual Studio Code installieren und ein Webbrowser nehmen
und mich mit Javascript und HTML beschäftigen. Das Schöne an Javascript, wenn du mit Javascript
anfangen, sind mehrere Sachen. Erstens, an Frontend Technologien, also HTML, CSS, Javascript
kommt heute eigentlich so gut wie niemand mehr vorbei. Und das nächste ist, du kannst
mit Javascript, sag mal, lag der Stream oder lag nur meine Vorschau? Du kannst mit Javascript
auch vieles andere machen, was nicht im Browser ist. Spätestens seit ein paar Jahren Node.js
so im Trend ist und so verbreitet ist, du kannst auch Backends mit Javascript machen
und du kannst sogar ganze Desktop Anwendungen mit Javascript machen. Das ist zwar bei manchen
Leuten etwas verpönt, aber es ist ziemlich weit verbreitet. Also, mich würde nicht wundern,
wenn viele Leute ein nicht geringer Teil ihrer Anwendung Javascript Desktop Programme, zum
Beispiel Discord. Discord ist Javascript. Discord ist quasi ein Browser in einer Desktop
Anwendung verpackt. Plus Node.js. Und Discord macht es allerdings etwas advanceder. Discord
hat wohl je nach Plattform noch einige C-Module drin, dass dieser ganze Kram etwas schneller
wird. Aber du willst ja wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt das nächste Discord programmieren.
Übrigens, ich habe ja letztens gesagt, ich verstehe nicht, warum Leute noch Teamspeak
verwenden. Ja, Bunsh habe ich uns letztens schon angeguckt. Da war ich überrascht, in
was man nicht alles Javascript-Runtimes implementieren kann. Teams ist auch Webgramm. Ja, sauvieles
Zeug ist Elektron-Webgramm. Ich habe doch letztens gesagt, ich verstehe nicht, warum
man 2022 noch Teamspeak verwendet. Weil es gibt ja immer noch Leute, wenn die CS zusammenspielen
oder Valorant zusammenspielen oder MMO gilden, die raiden zusammen, die sind noch im TS.
Und da habe ich doch letztens gesagt, TS, ich verstehe nicht, warum man 2022 TS verwendet.
Ich kann euch jetzt sagen, warum man 2022 TS verwendet. Weil es einfach keinerlei Lack
hat im Vergleich zu Discord. Discord hast du teilweise halbe Sekunde Verzögerung, im
Teamspeak sind es 10 Millisekunden oder so. Also im Teamspeak ist es als sitzender Typ
neben dir, im Discord ist es halt abfuck. Das war mir so gar nicht klar. Dachte eigentlich,
das ist nicht so schlimm. Die Quali ist besser, das hängt glaube ich
ein bisschen vom Discord-Server ab. Die Quali wird höher, je größer der Server ist, was
merkwürdig ist. Und man kann es selber hosten. Allerdings so einfach ist es nicht. Ich habe
gestern mal Just For Fun Pricing Teamspeak geguckt. Also wenn man einen wirklich ordentlichen,
Humble habe ich früher verwendet. Keine Ahnung, wie das jetzt ist, aber ich glaube, das kannst
du knicken. Ich habe mal geguckt, also die Preise sind
schon ein bisschen aus dem letzten Jahrtausend. Guck mal, wenn du einen richtig fetten Teamspeak-Server
haben willst, brauchst du, warum auch immer hier was von Virtual Server steht, das verstehe
ich nicht, weil du musst es eh selbst installieren. Das kostet 300 Dollar und nicht einmalige
Lizenz oder so. Nein, jährlich. Man kann natürlich auch die Free-Version nehmen. Die
Free-Version genau 32 Slots kostenlos. Und dann würde man sowas machen wie TS1.domain,
TS2.domain. Da könnte man da auch wahrscheinlich auf einer Domain mehrere Teamspeak-Server
mit 32 Slots laufen lassen. Aber die Lizenzierung ist schon ein bisschen aus dem letzten Jahrtausend
irgendwie. Wie gesagt, Windows Host. Welche Linux-Distro war das da? Das ist Manjaro mit
i3-WM, aber es ist Arch-based, aber man darf, weil sonst die ganzen Arch-Fanboys sagen,
das gilt nicht, man darf nicht sagen, dass ich Arch, by the way, use, auch wenn der Nightbot
das anders sieht, weil Manjaro ja kein richtiges Arch ist. Also Manjaro, by the way. Wir müssen
übrigens mal endlich, wir haben ja schon angefangen vor einem Monat oder so, eine
neue Streaming-VM zu machen, dass wir die alte wegschmeißen können, aber habe ich nicht
weiter gemacht. Das können wir eigentlich heute Mittag theoretisch fertig machen, dass
ich ein echtes, richtiges Arch, by the way, verwenden kann im Stream. Ich glaube, es hat
jeder mal gemacht. Ich glaube, jeder, der unvorbereitet Wim geöffnet hat, hat das Terminal
zugeklickt. Du hast Wim aufgemacht, also Leute, die ganz neu sind, und ich habe das bestimmt,
ich kann mich zwar nicht mehr erinnern, aber ich habe das bestimmt damals auch gemacht.
Du hast was in Wim geöffnet, hast keine Ahnung gehabt, wie du rauskommst, also hast du das
Terminal zugeklickt. Und das nächste Mal hast du die Datei aufgemacht und dann hat Wim
gesagt, oh, temporäres File gefunden, was wollen sie jetzt machen? Und dann wusstest
du nicht, was du machen solltest, du hast das Terminal wieder zugeklickt und Wim nie wieder
geöffnet. Ich glaube, so ging es vielen. Du warst in einem Krankenhaus wegen, was? Nein,
nicht einem komplizierten PC. Ich habe gedacht, du warst wegen einem komplizierten PC Setup.
Ich habe jetzt erst überlegt, was ist PC Setup? Sollte es irgendeine Krankheit sein?
Okay, im Krankenhaus hat man ein kompliziertes PC. Also der Arzt hatte auf dem Schreibtisch
einen Sincline mit irgendeinem Linux Desktop drauf, lief Firefox, mit dem Firefox ging es
zu einer Shitrix, ach du, ach du Scheiße. Und das Ganze unter der Haube wahrscheinlich
virtualisiert unter Windows XP oder so noch. Wie hieß dieses, wie hieß dieses Virtualisierungsding
von Microsoft unter Windows XP? Da gab es doch was. Die hatten doch so ein extra Virtualisierungsding
für Windows XP bei Microsoft, was die nie wieder aktualisiert haben. Virtual PC, ja.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum das ausgestorben ist. Ach, die haben die gekauft oder nie wieder
weiterentwickelt? Ja. Das war für die Zeit gar nicht so schlecht, gerade für Windows
Desktop-Virtualisierung. Na ja. Ja, aber Hyper-V ist für Desktop-Virtualisierung
das letzte Mal, als ich geguckt habe, nicht so geil gewesen. Deutlich komplizierter. Kann
man eigentlich, könnte ich jetzt einfach Hyper-V installieren? Ja, ok, Windows Features. Hyper,
Hyper-V, ok. Aber warum sollte ich das, wenn ich in meinem Fall immer Workstation verwenden
kann? Wie sieht es denn eigentlich mittlerweile aus mit ordentlichem OpenGL und RTX Unterstützung
in Hyper-V? Geht das mittlerweile? Mein VMware Workstation kann es mittlerweile brauchbar.
Hyper-Subscriber, ich habe nichts gesehen, aber trotzdem, Pog. Danke für die ganzen
Subs, falls ich übersehen habe. Hab nichts gesehen. Ist richtig mies immer noch. Ja,
das ging unter Virtual PC halbwegs brauchbar. Stimmt, das geht natürlich auch noch. Du
kannst explimische Commando-Zeilen-Tools ausführen. Ja, Teams ist auch Elektronen-Webgramm.
Ich meine, der Teamspeak Client ist halt sehr 2003 oder so. Ja, glaube ich dir. X-Fire,
Leute, X-Fire, kennt noch jemand? Warte mal, wie hieß das Ding? Was hat man ganz früher
verwendet hier? Voice-Chat. Kennt das noch jemand? Kennt noch jemand dieses Teil? Das
hat man so 2000 rum bei Online-Sachen verwendet. Richtig, richtig hängen gebliebenes Zeug.
Sieht tatsächlich ein bisschen wie Teamspeak teilweise sogar aus. Das waren Zeiten, wo
Leute ein paar Jahre später haben die auch noch Hamachi-VPN verwendet und sowas. Topics,
Dankeschön für den Sub. Ich habe das komplett aus. Das schaltet sich bei mir auch nicht
an. Heißt Virtual Server, dass man zwei virtuelle IPs bekommt? Was sollen virtuelle IPs sein?
Wenn du zwei VMs startest, bekommen die jeweils unterschiedliche IPs. Sonst wird es nämlich
schwierig mit nach außen zu kommunizieren. Die bekommen dann zwar keine IPs aus deinem
normalen internen Netzwerk, sondern wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein Host-Only-Nut-Netzwerk, was
dann über die IP vom Host rausgeht. Aber wenn du zwei VMs anlegst, kriegen die höchstwahrscheinlich
noch zwei IPs. Mit Arch-Installer. Ja, musst du. Deswegen habe ich auch noch nicht die
allerneueste, vor allem bei Workstation-Versionen. Ob du wirklich eine Lizenz kaufen musst? Ich
habe gehört, es gibt da angeblich auf GitHub-Listen, mit denen man eventuell, was ich jetzt natürlich
nicht empfehlen würde, aber ich habe damals meine Lizenz gekauft für 15€ oder so. Man
darf die bloß nicht offiziell bei VMWare kaufen, aber wenn man die offiziell bei VMWare
kauft, dann ist das viel, viel zu teuer. So, also, habe ich es geschafft. Ich hoffe,
es hat euch gefallen und lasst uns eine Runde gbanen. Windows-Lizenz, Windows-Lizenz, ja,
aber das kostet alles nicht viel. Windows-Lizenzen kriegst du von Apple und i irgendwo bei Amazon
oder sogar bei G2A und solch Dinger, also der Kram kostet nichts. Erinnert sich noch
einer an Windows 10 und dort diese Sachen mit den geleakten Dell-Zertifikaten. Also
ich kenne Leute, achso ja, gut, es funktioniert aber. Ich kenne Leute, die hatten bestimmt
20 Windows 10 Installationen und haben nicht einmal eine gültige Lizenz dafür gehabt.
Ja, es bescheuert die Preise, wo du kaufst dir irgendwas bei G2A oder so oder bei irgendeinem
oder bei Kinguin oder sonst wo und wenn du nicht willst, kannst du theoretisch bei Amazon
sogar kaufen. Amazon, Windows, mach Windows 11 oder Windows 10. Ja, 15 Euro, das geht
noch deutlich günstiger. Stimmt, darf nicht zu günstig sein, sonst verklagen die dich
wieder wie letztens bei dem Video, was wir geguckt haben. Wo sie gesagt haben, das muss
der doch wissen, weil der auf Ebay was kauft. Ganz ehrlich, was man da angeblich alles wissen
muss. Vielleicht sind es irgendwelche Konkursmassen oder sonst was, was weiß ich denn, wo die
Lizenz herkommt. Wenn ich über Amazon eine Windows-Lizenz kaufe, gehe ich davon aus,
dass das eine echte Windows-Lizenz ist, weil ich mir doch keine Gedanken drüber. Was soll
das? Wie sollen die Anwender mal in Ruhe lassen? Kackel, Alter. Ja, gut, das kann hier passieren.
Also, gut. Was gucken wir uns als erstes an? Ich würde sagen, wir lassen uns eine Runde
Levelcap jebaiten und ich predikte jetzt schon mal wieder das... Ja, kann man machen, das
Zeug kostet nicht viel. Also, wer das beim offiziellen Job kauft, da weiß ich auch nicht.
Wir lassen uns jetzt mal wieder Levelcap jebaiten und ich predikte jetzt schon mal das Levelcap-Video,
der sagt, es gibt massive, huge, hype Changes für Battlefield 2042 und dann erzählt er
was und nach dem Motto, okay, der linke Handschuh von was auch immer irgendeinem Specialist
ist jetzt blau anstatt grün, massive Changes und dann erzählt er über andere Dinger und
am Ende des Videos sagt er, fragt er uns dann und denken wir jetzt, dass mit diesen Handschuh-Changes
Battlefield 2042 in einem besseren Spot ist und was denken wir dazu, sagt es in den Kommentaren.
So, also ungefähr so wird das Levelcap-Video ablaufen. Gamescom 2022, ganz ehrlich, ich
habe noch nichts von der Gamescom 2022 gehört und ich glaube ja auch, die haben sich, die
schaufeln sich gerade ihr eigenes Grab. Man hat nämlich gesehen in der ganzen Corona-Zeit,
dass Messen wahnsinnig overrated, outdated, jebaited sind. So, also Levelcap, erzähl uns.
Ich glaube, ich muss ein bisschen.
Geht doch. Significant Improvements. Oh, man hat, man hat übrigens bis heute nicht gefixt,
wisst ihr das eigentlich, dass man bis heute nicht gefixt hat, dass man nach links und
rechts gucken kann in Battlefield 2042? Also die hatten ja mal einen Patch rausgebracht,
oder was nach oben und unten gucken. Die haben ja mal einen Patch rausgebracht, dass man
nicht mehr nach links und rechts gucken kann in einem Ego-Shooter und das haben die bis
heute nicht gefixt. Du musst immer noch selbst in deinen Settings-Ordner gehen und das löschen.
Also, das ist halt absolute Unfähigkeit hoch 10.
Ich, ich, wisst ihr, was ich... Warte mal, zeig nochmal, Soap. Oh, mein Gott, ich, ich
wollte, hier. Irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, was es ist mit den Modern Warfare-Entwicklern,
die stehen da, die stehen da drauf, dass ihre Charaktere irgendwie so Pulse-Bäckchen haben.
Das war bei Price auch schon so. Der Typ, der sieht in echt überhaupt nicht so aus,
aber ist irgendwie in-game, stehen die auch so Bäckchen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie
so, so fetisch der Entwickler ist oder so.
A brand new Division-Game is on the way and much more in this week in gaming.
Das ist aber nur in Modern Warfare so.
Aha, gibt es jetzt einen Server-Browser? Lass mich raten, nein, gibt es nicht. Also
im einen Server-Browser und Map-Selection, das wäre tatsächlich mal Quality of Life,
aber sowas, das geht natürlich nicht.
Ach, nach einem Jahr hat man das jetzt hingekriegt.
Ja, man hat, man hat dafür, das zu erkennen, hat man gerade über einen Monat nach Release
gebraucht von dem DLC. Nice, GG Eats.
Und wo sind die Quality of Life-Improvements?
Aha.
Na, auf die Idee würde ich jetzt nicht kommen, mein Cache-Folder per OneDrive zu sünden.
Oh.
Player-Stats-Page.
Wahnsinn.
Okay, und wo sind die krassen Quality of Life-Changes jetzt?
Jetzt, was ist nicht, kriegt das, wird das doch nie kriegen.
Aber ja, ich finde, das ist auch etwas, wo irgendwie das so, der originale Ghost hat ja
keine Maske auf, der hatte so ein Tuch auf mit einer Maske drauf, was irgendwie noch
einen gewissen Hauch der Glaubwürdigkeit hatte, dass einer mit einer echten Maske darum
rennt, ist eher...
Ja.
Auf Black Ops 6 haben natürlich auch alle gewartet nach den letzten...
Das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Nächstes Jahr machen sie ein Jahr Pause mit Call of Duty.
Gut, die Manni sagen viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Nee, es gab nicht Black Ops 5, es gab Vanguard.
Boi.
Also, ich glaube, die Mainline-Titel God of War, die haben noch nie verkackt.
Ich meine, man kann sich über diesen Vita-Ableger und die ein paar anderen sein, kann sich bestimmt
streiten, aber die Haupttitel der Serie waren immer ziemlich nice.
Jetzt weiß ich endlich, wie sich dieses Genre nennt, Tactical Extraction Game, weil mir
war auch schon immer klar, dass es nicht wirklich Battle Royale ist.
Ich wusste nicht, dass ich das Tactical Extraction Game nennt.
Wieder was gelernt.
Wie, wie?
Moment, Moment, habe ich das jetzt richtig gehört?
Die Entwickler hören darauf, was die Leute haben.
Das ist ein
tidenlanges Spiel.
expected version.
In game is available on YouTube, however the weapon itself is technically hidden from
players.
It should launch with the Serpent Moon content update in the near future.
Riot Games has announced that starting in August it will increase the price of League
of Legends in game currencies.
The publisher pinned the blame on worldwide inflation and currency fluctuations across
different regions.
They noted that they conduct annual reviews of their pricing
anyway but that this year's price changes are more significant than usual.
To counter the price changes, Riot will host a series of promotions before the change is
made.
Players will be able to earn double coins with every purchase made for the rest of July.
However, things will go back to normal once the update hits on August 19th.
Price changes vary from region to region but generally things are going up by about 10%.
To say fans are annoyed would be a huge understatement.
Blizzard published details on Diablo Immortal's first post-launch content drop.
The free-to-play mobile title launched into open beta on June 2nd, it was met with varying
shades of gray with a version higher than the beta bas intact.
Dieses Kostüms ist mehr Zeit geflossen als in wirklich in-game Bekenning.
...extreme monetization.
The latest update kicks off a new season with three battle passes, weekend events and numerous balance changes.
However, as you'd expect...
Battlefield Spielerzahlen, sehr gute Idee. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wir gucken erstmal New-World-Spielerzahlen.
Ach du Scheiße!
Haha, das ist ja noch weniger geworden seit dem letzten Mal.
Alter, die sind ja mal, die sind ja mal so im Arsch, Alter.
Was zum...
Boah, sind die im Arsch, Alter.
Ich habe im Hinterkopf immer noch, dass so 20.000 Leute oder so spielen.
Okay, es ist aktuell, ja, sind da immer noch 20.000.
Ja, kommt doch, kommt doch hin, was ich gesagt habe, irgendwie um die 20.000.
Nee, das ist, dann ist es doch nicht so schlimm.
Ich habe mich verguckt, ich dachte, das hier wäre 24-hour-Peaks.
Weil ich hatte immer noch im Kopf, spielen so 20.000 Leute.
Krass, aber die sind so heftig abgeschissen.
Okay, gucken wir mal, was die hier machen.
8.000 Spieler, ja, gut.
Ich meine, ehrlich gesagt, es war klar.
Das habe ich ja auch immer im Video gesagt.
2, 3 Wochen und die Spielerzahlen sind halt wieder unten da, wo sie vorher waren.
Okay, vielleicht nicht ganz so krass unten, wie sie vorher waren.
Vorher waren sie auf 2.600, jetzt sind sie auf 6.500.
Aber es ist halt, ich meine, hallo.
Guck mal hier, angefangen hat es mal da und da.
Fast nichts, fast nichts zu sehen, da piek.
Steam, ja.
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie es bei Battlefield, okay.
Battlefield 5.
Hahaha, gut, Battlefield 5 hat einfach mal, doppelt bis je nachdem, dreifach so viele
Spieler wie Battlefield 2042, Alter.
Battlefield 1.
Sogar Battlefield 1 hat mehr Spieler. Battlefield 4?
Okay, Battlefield 4 hat ein bisschen weniger, alles klar.
Wobei es das lange Zeit auch nicht auf Steam gab, ja.
Battlefield 3?
Okay, Battlefield 3 spielt über Steam keine Sau.
Battlefield 3 ist glaube ich immer noch mit das meistverkaufte.
Gucken wir mal.
Also Battlefield 3 war richtig gut dabei.
Battlefield 3, ja.
Zu Recht, zu Recht, ja.
Die Leute erkennen halt doch irgendwie was, was taugt.
Die Pre-Orderzahlen und die Initialen der ersten Woche sind nicht so entscheidend in dem Fall,
weil die Leute haben halt richtig viel Vorschusslorbein gegeben für 20.42 und haben es dann gekauft.
Aber danach sind halt die Sales so krass eingebraucht, das hast du auch gesehen.
Die hatten ja schon ein free Weekend irgendwie zwei Wochen oder so nach Release.
Oder an Weihnachten konntest du ja irgendwie umsonst spielen und sowas.
Also wir gucken jetzt erstmal kurz, Level Cap fertig.
Übrigens, habe ich das richtig gelesen, dass in China Diablo Immortal jetzt gar nicht rauskommen soll?
Was ist aber auch hartgeheim? Ja, war ich auch.
Bei der Beta war ich dann schon ein bisschen verhaltener, als ich es spielen konnte.
Aber spätestens zwei, drei Tage nach dem Release, wo ich es viel gespielt habe, war mir klar, das ist für'n Arsch.
Fertig standen.
Collection, but rather to have them polished, so modders can use them instead. Fans are delighted that 343 is not only supporting modding like this, but that it's active.
Genau, da bin ich ja froh, da bin ich ja froh, dass wir das gesagt haben. Ja, also wir haben jetzt, wir haben uns ja da unterhalten im Stream und da haben wir, glücklicherweise, waren wir beide mega gehypt, vor allem als der, als das Ding aus, als der Typ aus dem Jet gesprungen ist und in RPG
und so, was ja in dem Spiel gar nicht wirklich vorkommt. Aber wir haben glücklicherweise gesagt, ja Trailers, es sieht alles mega aus, aber am Ende kann es sich ja auch wie Kacke spielen. Zum Glück haben wir uns das offen gelassen und haben das gesagt, weil es spielt sich ja auch wie Kacke.
Oh Mann, Alter. Gaming-Hersteller 2022.
Spielt jemand von euch Star Citizen? Und wenn ja, ist das ein Spiel, was man theoretisch, also ich hab jetzt nicht vor, interessiert mich halt von euch, ich hab nicht vor, es zu spielen, aber ist das denn ein Spiel, was man wirklich jetzt irgendwie auch am Stück spielen könnte?
Also, können ich jetzt beispielsweise das nächste halbe Jahr Star Citizen jeden Tag ein paar Stunden spielen oder? Ist ja noch in Entwicklung, ja es wird, es wird immer in Entwicklung sein.
Gibt nix zu tun, okay. Ja, super. Was ist eigentlich aus der Singleplayer-Kampagne geworden, die sollte doch schon vor zwei Jahren rauskommen.
Riesig den Sleeper, Alter. Ein Division-Game und dann auch noch Mobile, da hab ich jetzt drauf gewartet. Da hab ich ja, da kann ich mich ja kaum halten.
Guckt euch mal die Spring-Animation an, Alter. Guckt euch die Spring-Animation an. Sieht das scheiße aus, Alter.
Hast du kein Phone? Nein, dafür hab ich kein Phone. Sekunde, ich hab grad mein Mikrofon geprägt.
Okay, geht wieder.
Ach, lebt das noch? Gibt's das noch? Das ist doch, das haben die doch vor zehn Jahren oder so schon angekündigt. Ich dachte, das ist Dead, ich dachte nicht, dass es jemals kommt.
Es gibt's wieder. Wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt einfach der Assassin's Creed Shift-Teil ausgekoppelt und so ein bisschen cash-crappen, wobei das Spiel muss so viel Geld gekostet haben, wenn es so lange in Entwicklung war.
Da fällt mir noch was anderes ein. Hatten nicht die Ark-Leute auch so ein Piraten-Game rausgebracht, was mega gefloppt ist? War da nicht irgendwas, was brutalste technische Probleme hatte und alle nur noch geflamed haben? War das Atlas? Ja, kann sein. Ja, ja, genau. Ja, das kann sein. Das ist wahrscheinlich immer, das ist auch Dead Game, oder?
Naja. Also, ich bin ja eh kein großer Fan des Terminator-Franchises. Also, ich muss sagen, den ersten und zweiten Teil fand ich schon cool damals. Gerade den zweiten Teil. Danach konntest du eigentlich alles bis heute mehr oder weniger vergessen. Terminator Games hab ich, weiß ich nicht, es ist jetzt nicht, wo ich sage, 2022 hätt ich echt mal Bock auf ein krasses Open-World-Terminator-Game, aber okay.
Warum ich? Das konnte mir ja bis heute auch keiner wirklich erklären, warum Terminator, warum die Zähne haben müssen. Also, so Zähne, die echt, so echte Zähne. Wozu?
Soll ihr Menschen imitieren? Ja, weil der Rest, weil der Rest auch äußerst menschlich aussieht.
Ja, so ist das, Chet. So ist es leider im Jahr 2022, was Games angeht. Gefreut aufs neue Division-Game, zack, Mobile-Game. Ja, so ist es halt, ne?
Das kann ja immer passieren. Blizzard hat's vorgemacht mit Diablo Immortal. Ich mein, ich kann's bis heute nicht verstehen, wie entfernt man von seiner Fanbase sein kann, dass man ein Game auf der BlizzCon vorstellt, als neues Diablo, wo die Leute jetzt Jahre damals schon drauf gewartet haben.
Und dann kommt man mit diesen Mobile-Gamen und man wirklich gedacht hat, es ist was Geiles und die Leute freuen sich. Und anstatt ihnen zu zeigen, ich mein, es wäre ja auch die Möglichkeit gewesen, es wäre ja durchaus die Möglichkeit gewesen, nach diesem verkackten Auftakt zu sagen, wir machen jetzt ein richtig gutes Mobile-Game und kein Asia-NetEase-Cash-Crab-Game.
Als man allen gezeigt hätte, guck mal hier, ihr habt uns zwar verteufelt dafür, aber wir haben ein richtig gutes Game gemacht. Aber nein, man hat im Prinzip genau das erfüllt, was die Leute befürchtet haben.
Tja, na Blizzard, wie ich bei mir im Video gesagt hab, das was wir teilweise über Blizzard im Kopf haben, gibt's halt nicht mehr. Die Leute sind nicht umsonst die letzten Jahre über abgehauen.
Also viele, manche wurden gegangen und letztendlich ist es eigentlich nur noch ein weiterer Gaming-Hersteller, der auf die Fans bzw. auf die Games wenig Wert legt.
Früher haben die Games entwickelt, weil sie selbst diese Games spielen wollten, zumindest hat sich das so angefühlt. Die haben Spiele entwickelt, die sich so spielen, als wollten die Leute wirklich was entwickeln, was sie selbst gerne spielen wollen.
Ist jetzt halt nicht mehr so.
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier? Ein Witz.
Was ist Fake? Ich würde sagen, wahrscheinlich beides.
Was hat denn Renzo wieder eingestellt?
Howmatter Change Your Smart Home.
Bei dem Kerl mit seinen 500 Apps, der brauchte seine 500 und eine App.
Ich wurde gehackt. Darknet Auftragsarbeit.
Okay Leute, das ist bestimmt massivster Pains-Champ dieses Video, aber der Titel ist so jebaited.
Das müssen wir mal durch zappen. Ich glaube nicht, dass das wirklich damit was zu tun hat, aber das ist ganz schrecklich wahrscheinlich.
Oh Gott, das wird grausam Leute. Pains-Champ Video Incoming.
Ich kann den Channel nicht muten, weil ich gar nicht eingeloggt bin.
Das ist bestimmt ganz furchtbar schrecklich, aber das kann ich mir jetzt nicht gleichgeben.
3D-Trucke, dreckiges Geheimnis. Ja, sie dauern lange. Und sie bestehen aus Plastik.
Oh, Flappy Bird. Das ist auch so ein Hype-Game gewesen für drei Wochen.
Guck mal, ich krieg meine eigenen Videos empfohlen. Das gucken wir jetzt nicht Leute.
Ich muss das aber anmachen und im Hintergrund laufen lassen, weil...
Kann man sich hier nicht muten?
Weil Watch Time ist das wichtigste. Ich muss immer meine eigenen Videos anklicken, wenn ich die empfohlen kriege.
Und durchlaufen lassen. Ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie es ist.
Das beste, was ihr für einen Content-Creator machen könnt, dem euch der Content gefällt. Das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Das werden euch die meisten wahrscheinlich auch so sagen.
Scheiß auf Werbeblocker oder kein Werbeblocker. Guckt mit Werbeblocker, wenn ihr wollt.
Aber guckt die Videos komplett. Und sei es nur, wenn ihr feststellt, ab hier hab ich keinen Bock mehr.
Lasst das Video durchlaufen.
Das ist das beste, was ihr machen könnt für Content-Creator, wo euch der Content gefällt.
Ach stimmt, ich hab hier einen VOD-Kanal, wusste ich ja gar nicht.
Wie heißt denn der? Hier, Max FPS VODs.
Tatsächlich. Der ist ja nicht von mir. Den haben Leute aus dem Discord erstellt und laden dort immer die Streams hoch.
Ja.
Ich mache den Digitalführerschein. Kackel, Alter.
Hat eigentlich schon, jetzt war blöde Frage, ich weiß nicht, hat jemand Admin-Zugriff auf diesen Kanal, gerade der gerade da ist?
Hat hier irgendjemand schon irgendwann mal einen Kommentar gepostet unter eines der Videos?
Ja.
Okay.
Also ihr habt angefangen, Streams hochzuladen ab Anfang 2021, seh ich das richtig?
Windows Area war mal da. Oh, in dem Stream, wo ich über die Videos habe ich nicht abgelästert, ich habe abgelästert über dieses Windows Tuning Pack.
Ja, es wäre halt cool, wenn man nach meist kommentiert sortieren könnte. Geht halt nicht.
Wie gesagt, das ist nicht von mir, da laden Leute hier aus dem Discord die VODs hoch, habe ich nichts mit zu tun.
So, also was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an? Okay, komm, komm, wir sind...
Leute, ich verspreche euch, wenn das Video zu pains-champig wird, machen wir aus. Und ich skippe, ich skippe durch, ich skippe durch.
Ich wusste einfach, Leute, das wird ganz schlimm. Ich habe schon im Gefühl... Natürlich.
Es wird schlimm, es wird ganz furchtbar schlimm. Ich weiß es jetzt schon. Ja.
Plottwist.
Wird der Kanal von irgendwem gesponsert? Nochmal kurz gucken.
Nee. Okay.
Okay, Leute, eigentlich sollte diese Woche ein anderes Video kommen. Bis jetzt geht's. Ja, ja, bis jetzt, bis jetzt geht's.
Zum Thema Krypto Trading Signale von YouTubern. Die haben wir jetzt ein paar Wochen getestet und wollten einfach mal zeigen, können die was oder können die nichts.
Was für Dinger?
Okay, Leute, eigentlich sollte diese Woche ein anderes Video kommen, nämlich zum Thema Krypto Trading Signale von...
Trading Signale von YouTubern. Okay, da sieht man mal, ich bin echt zu Boomer.
Ich kann aus diesem ganzen Satz nichts Sinnvolles an Informationen extrahieren, wo ich verstehen würde, was er gerade gesagt hätte.
Von YouTubern. Die haben wir jetzt ein paar Wochen getestet und wollten einfach mal zeigen, können die was oder können die nichts.
Aber dieses Video ist jetzt tatsächlich relativ spontan dazwischen gekommen. Vor zwei Wochen haben wir nämlich ein Video gemacht zum Thema Darknet und Hackerguides.
Die haben wir dort runtergeladen bzw. uns gekauft und dann innerhalb von 24 Stunden probiert, selber hacken zu lernen.
Beziehungsweise ein zweites Handy von Chris wollte wir hacken mit diesen ganzen Tools.
Ein paar von euch haben in die Kommentare geschrieben, dass wir uns damit schon strafbar gemacht hätten, weil wir haben die gekauft, runtergeladen und im Endeffekt benutzt.
Und da habe ich den lieben Rechtsanwalt Christian Solm...
Na wen sonst? Der ist ja mittlerweile auch überall.
... wieder an den Pranger gestellt werden für. Und das ist an dieser Stelle seine Antwort.
Okay, ich spule jetzt mal ein bisschen vor, weil ich will ja wissen, was da rauskommt, was mit den Videos vom letzten Jahr war.
Der selbst wenn das hacken hat, der versucht, Freunde macht und selbst wenn es irgendwie ein Prank ist oder ein Scherz oder so, tatsächlich strafbar.
Und das habe ich auch im Fazit benannt, möchte aber...
Das ist jetzt nicht, sondern nicht krasser Hacker-Shit, oder?
Also ich meine, das kann jeder verwenden, N-Croc. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das ausspricht.
Das ist ein Service, da kannst du beispielsweise dein SSH-Port scheren oder einen Server, der hinter einer Firewall steht, tunneln und so.
Das ist eigentlich was, was recht, sagen wir mal, beliebt ist zu benutzen. Das ist jetzt kein super krasses Hacking-Tool.
Das habe ich auch im Fazit benannt, möchte aber an dieser Stelle auch nochmal, dass die Autorität das sagt.
Es kommen folgende Straftatbestände in Betracht.
Da haben wir zunächst mal 202 von Martin Frost oder auch einen Simon in Open Mind gelernt, dass viele dort nur darauf aussehen.
Das heißt, die bieten irgendwelche Hackdienstleistungen an. Hey, ich hack Iphones in 24 Stunden, YouTube-Accounts.
Also nicht mal das FBI hat Iphones mit einem ordentlichen Passwort aufgekriegt.
Da macht es der Instagram-Hacker wahrscheinlich auch nicht in 24 Stunden.
Dann kaufs, dann kriegst du keine Antwort mehr oder wirst geblockt, so wie wir.
Weil die eben darauf spekulieren, dass wenn du das jetzt bei deiner Ex-Freundin machst, du ja nicht zur Polizei gehen kannst und sagst,
ey, ich habe 300 Dollar bezahlt, dass meine Ex-Freundin gehackt wird, weil du ja im Endeffekt in dem Moment eine Straftat ausgeübt hast.
Beziehungsweise eine Anstiftung zu einer Straftat.
Deshalb sind wir diesmal anders vorgegangen. Wir haben uns angeguckt, was verkaufen die Leute unter Fraud und Hacking.
Das sind meistens Tools, Guides.
Ich würde aber nie sagen, ich würde doch nie beauftragen, hackt das iPhone meiner Freundin.
Also wenn ich theoretisch sowas beauftragen würde, was ich nicht machen würde, weil ich weiß, dass es zum größten alles Scam ist,
würde ich sagen, ich habe das Passwort für mein altes iPhone verloren.
Und da sind wichtige Daten drauf, hackt das mal.
Kartenbetrügerei und so weiter, aber eher so Anleitung.
Ob es dann meins ist oder nicht, ist aber was anderes.
Der wirklich viele positive Bewertungen hatte, ein paar Orders platziert.
Eins war dieser Hacker Guide aus dem Video, den ihr gesehen habt.
Ein paar andere Dinge haben wir einfach nur gekauft, um Kontakt aufzubauen bzw. so ein bisschen Reputation.
Das heißt gekauft, schnell bezahlt, in den Chat rein, ein, zwei Zeilen.
Hey, danke schön, hat perfekt funktioniert.
Glaub ich dir sofort, dass die Reaper.
Und dann eine Woche später bin ich beigegangen und habe gesagt,
hey, wir haben jetzt bei dir eigentlich alles irgendwie gekauft, wir sind super happy.
Aber bietest du denn auch so eine Dienstleistung an?
Also kannst du vielleicht auch selber hacken, weil das würde ich auch gerne in Anspruch nehmen.
Das hat dann gedauert, gedauert und dann schiebt er zurück.
Ich muss auch sagen, diese Poren sind manchmal down, man wird getime outet und so weiter.
Und irgendwann schrieb er, nee, das selber macht das nicht.
Oder sie, man weiß es ja nicht.
Aber ich kenne jemanden.
Hackerinnen bestimmt.
Die Gruppe, die macht das, aber die würden mit uns wahrscheinlich nicht zusammenarbeiten.
Warum? Weil wir einfach zu wenig History haben.
Simon hat uns ja schon für das letzte Video von diesen Hacking Guides ein bisschen History gegeben.
Seine alten Benutzernamen, auch so ein paar Insights, die man eben nicht kannte.
Und er sagt, das reicht da wahrscheinlich nicht mal aus.
Man bräuchte noch mehr.
Und man hat schon gemerkt, okay, der Typ ist skeptisch, aber der hat eben auch Geld gerochen.
Weil diese Vermittlung zu dieser Hacker Group, die kostet.
Und dann wurde er, glaube ich, irgendwann schwach.
Und sagt, okay, weißt du was, ja, kann sein.
Diese ganzen Poren waren auch da.
Er braucht Kohle.
Er konnte das nicht wirklich belegen und er konnte auch nicht wirklich gucken, ob das eben stimmte.
Dann hat er gesagt, komm, lass uns einfach mal zu Jabber.
Ich in dem Moment Jabber.
Ich gebe das so bei Google ein, finde irgendwas.
Keine Ahnung gehabt, ehrlich gesagt.
Haben mir dann irgendwas geschickt, so Pitkin.
Xamp.
Okay, da sieht man, er hat nicht wirklich Ahnung von dem, was er da erzählt muss.
Was er da erzählt muss er auch nicht haben.
Also das muss man sagen.
Das sind absolut keine Hacker Tools.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Instant Messenger.
Und Jabber war zu Zeiten, wo jetzt noch nicht so viel Skype und später Teams und Discord
war ziemlich verbreitet.
Also Jabber und Pitkin ist ein ganz normaler Cross-Platform Instant Messenger, der verschiedene
Protokolle unterstützt.
Der konnte damals ICQ, der kann Xamp, also Jabber und das ist auch ein Source Tool auf
GitHub.
Das ist wirklich keinerlei Hacker Tools und Jabber auch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, Martin Frost angerufen und der sagt, ja, das klingt nach Szenen.
Ein verschlüsselter Messenger, den lebt man sich runter und der wird wohl offen.
Du brauchst das Ding, das Off-The-Record-Messaging-Plugin für Pitkin.
Das geht.
Das ist relativ beliebt.
Das stimmt.
Das habe ich früher auch verwendet.
Das ist, du installierst, vielleicht kann es Pitkin mittlerweile auch schon standardmäßig.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ne, das ist nicht.
Das ist nur mit Plugin.
Du brauchst hier, ich zeige dir, Pitkin Off-The-Record-Plugin.
Das braucht man dafür.
Falls es das noch ist, wahrscheinlich 2016, vielleicht ein bisschen alt.
Wie gesagt, ich habe das ewig nicht mehr verwendet.
Damals war es das hier zumindest.
Das hat folgendermaßen funktioniert.
Du hast ein Plugin, beide brauchten das Plugin.
Du hast Leute geedit und dann konntest du mit denen verschlüsselt kommunizieren.
Allerdings gab es zwei Schritte.
Du hattest noch die Möglichkeit zu verifizieren, dass dein Gegenüber auch wirklich dein Gegenüber
ist.
Das konntest du auf verschiedene Arten machen.
Das einfachste war mit einem Passwort.
Sprich, mit einem Kollege hast du dich getroffen, hast gesagt, wir machen jetzt ein geheimes
Haus, Omega Poggers Kekkel und dann authentifizieren wir uns über OTR im Pitkin gegenseitig.
Dann konntest du sagen, ich möchte das Gegenüber verifizieren.
Dann hast du geheime Frage eingegeben, was ist das geheime Passwort.
Der hat dann gesagt, Omega Poggers Kekkel.
Dann hat das Plugin erkannt, der weiß die Antwort und ihr kennt euch.
Dann war das richtig authentifiziert.
Das heißt, du kannst sicher sein, dass du weißt, mit wem du sprichst und das Ganze
ist verschlüsselt.
Zu der Zeit, als ich das benutzt habe, war diese OTR-Geschichte voll angesagt.
Dass das echte Hacker-Mans verwenden, das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Warum nicht?
Das ist alles Open Source von Anfang bis Ende, was ja gewisses Vertrauen schafft bei diesen
Leuten das zu verwenden.
Es sind keine komischen Messenger-Apps über externe Gehosted-Apps auf irgendwelchen Servern,
wo du nicht weißt, was passiert.
Du brauchst keine Apps ins Zählen, wo du nicht weißt, aus was sie bestehen.
Das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das durchaus in Hacker-Kreisen verwendet wird.
Ich nutze bei solchen Leuten, die tendenziell eine Dienstleistung verkaufen, die anscheinend
ausgeführt wird.
Also eben nicht so ein Scam.
Ich sage es dann also wirklich wie in einem Film vor meinem Rechner und habe das gemacht,
runtergeladen, mit Martin telefoniert, Server eingegeben und so weiter.
Jetzt übertreibt man nicht.
Pidgin zu installieren, ist ein Installer runterladen, dreimal auf weiterklicken.
Also das ist jetzt nicht als Wettestätig krasser Hacker-Shit-Shot.
Eines Tages stand das Ding und ich habe diesem Typen eine Nachricht auf diesem Jabber-Pidgin-Klein-Geschichte.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das Ganze ist eben verschlüsselt.
Nein, es ist nicht verschlüsselt, weil da unten steht nicht privat.
Das Ganze ist eben verschlüsselt und ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich habe mich nicht getraut,
in dem Moment OBS anzumachen, weil ich mir so dachte, okay, wenn hier alles verschlüsselt
ist und du lädst extra noch so ein Protokoll runter, so ein Sicherheitsding und so, ich
mache jetzt OBS an, dann wird da wahrscheinlich stehen, yo, das wird gerade recallen.
Ähnlich wie bei Snapchat, wenn dir einer irgendwas schickt und du machst...
Ganz bestimmt.
...einen Screenshot, dann wird das ja angezeigt.
Und deshalb mussten wir an dieser Stelle diese Szene eben auch nachfragen.
Ich meine, okay, ich finde, das Video ist okay, das ist bei weitem nicht so schlimm,
wie ich mir das im Vorfeld vorgestellt habe, aber es wäre durchaus sinnvoll gewesen für
dieses Selbstexperiment, sich vielleicht jemand daneben zu setzen, der so grob ein Plan hat,
was abgeht.
Ja, und so verlief dieser Chat.
Also erstmal keine Namen, ich habe sofort nachgefragt, können die denn alles hacken?
Also jede Social Media Plattform, Instagram, YouTube, er sagt alles, überhaupt keine.
Na klar.
Okay, wie teuer ist es, wenn du jetzt den Kontakt hast?
Dann habe ich mich verwundert.
Easy, easy, alles hack, hack the planet, alles, ja.
Er sagt nämlich 10 Dollar.
Ich sage 10 Dollar, also dafür jetzt der ganze Aufwand, Jabber runterladen, verschlüsselter
Client und so weiter.
Okay, schick mir seine Adresse, wir haben nicht lange überlegt, hast das Geld dort
hingesendet und jetzt kommt es, die Bitcoins sind angekommen und dann schickt er mir 3 E-Mail-Adressen
und wir blören jetzt an dieser Stelle diese Adresse, aber auch der Name davor war wie
aus einem Film, Who Am I oder so, irgendein Hacker-Film.
Er schickt also diese Adressen, dazu einen Code und sagt, pack diesen Code in den Betreff
und melde dich innerhalb von 24 Stunden, weil die sind busy und danach funktioniert der
Zugang nicht mehr.
Ich bin ehrlich zu euch Leute, ich sitze da vor meinem Laptop, lese das, ich muss schmunzeln,
okay, keine Ahnung, warum der Typ jetzt nur 10 Dollar von mir genommen hat, habe dann
trotzdem einen Web.de-Account gemacht, einen Einsider hingepackt, oben den Code rein, habe
gesagt, jo, ich habe da einen Account, den ich gerne hacken würde.
Erst mal schön bei einer E-Mail-Adresse registrieren, irgendwo mit Klarnamen.
Ich habe den Laptop zugeklappt, habe natürlich nie gedacht, dass da wirklich eine Antwort
kommt.
Nächster Morgen, ich setze mich an meinen Rechner, mache meinen ganzen Stuff, denke
an, ah, okay, stimmt, ich kann mal bei Web.de gucken, schaue rein und habe tatsächlich von
denen eine Mail bekommen, und zwar um 6.07 Uhr in der Früh, klar, Zeitverschiebung und
so weiter, keine Ahnung, wo die herkommen.
Die schreiben, Client, yes indeed, we can do that for you, any social media hack...
Besser, erst mal gleich die richtige Schriftart.
Natürlich auch Instagram, das hatte ich auch in meiner ersten Mail geschrieben, habe gesagt,
hey, ganz explizit könnt ihr einen Instagram-Account hacken.
Dann sagen sie, wir bekommen den Full Access, also wir würden den so hacken, dass man Login-Daten
hat, Passwort und so weiter, oder, keine Ahnung, was damit gemeint ist, sie können auch alles
mit dem Account machen, was man will, vielleicht irgendwelche Bilder ändern, vielleicht dafür
sorgen, dass, keine Ahnung, irgendwas mit dem Account passiert oder so.
Payment ist natürlich Bitcoin und das Ganze würde nur ein bis drei Tage dauern, bis
wir sozusagen Access bekommen, nachdem, klar, das Geld bei denen drauf ist.
Dann fand ich ganz witzig...
Er müsste halt wissen, wie dieser Instagram-Account abgesichert ist, ja.
Ich habe keinen Instagram-Account, ich weiß nicht, ob Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung Pflicht
ist, ich weiß nicht, was die sonst an Vorkehrungen haben, zu, was weiß ich, wie Timeouten-Sessions
zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, mal gucken.
Wenn man nicht komplett happy ist, also wenn ich sage, ich weiß nicht, ich kam irgendwie
ein bisschen zu spät oder so, gibt es eine Refund-Policy, ja, keine Ahnung.
Ja, ja, ganz bestimmt.
Auf dem Käuferschutz oder so, auf web.de und wenn ich weiter mit denen entscheiden will,
ganz bestimmt, dann soll ich einfach auf diese E-Mail antworten.
Habe ich natürlich sofort gemacht und die wollten aber schon nochmal wissen, okay,
woher, ja, bevor wir jetzt gleich ins Eingemachte gehen, bevor du uns direkt das Target nennst
und so, woher hast du unseren Kontakt?
Na, die waren also auch wieder so ein bisschen suspicious, haben gesagt, hey, wir wissen,
es gibt Leute, die verkaufen...
Haben die geschrieben...
Ja, ich meine, naja, gut.
Auf geht's.
Ich habe kurz überlegt, meinen Instagram-Account zu nehmen, weil ich so dachte, okay, wenn
wir es wirklich schaffen, keine Ahnung, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich auch viele Nachrichten
bekommen, so, hey, Tom, wurdest du vielleicht gehackt und so weiter, naja, vielleicht hatte
ich erst gedacht, lass ich das Profilbild ändern, aber dann dachte ich mir, hm, vielleicht
ist er nicht so schlau, so ein Video darüber zu machen, sich selber zu hacken, also vielleicht
gefällt es auch Instagram nicht.
Deshalb habe ich einen Fake erstellt und zwar den lieben...
Das ist aber doch ein bisschen auffällig, oder?
Wenn der Account erstellt wurde, nachdem man den Hacking-Aufrag gegeben hat.
Das ist doch irgendwie ein bisschen...
Weiß nicht...
Das ist Sus, oder?
Franjo Beutlin.
Na, Franjo Beutlin ist Klavierliebhaber, ist ein Feuermacher im Herzen der Frauen, Eigenheim,
nein, danke, das kommt für ihn nicht in Frage, kreiert Filme auf anderen Plattformen und
ich habe einfach von Google-Bilder so einen typischen F***boy, so ein Modelbild einfach
genommen.
Okay, das ist natürlich sehr...
Auf der anderen Seite...
Ich habe das eingefügt, ich hoffe, der guckt hier nicht dieses Video jetzt und das war
im Endeffekt der Account.
So, dann ging es natürlich um das Passwort und ich weiß ja noch gerade Thema Brute Force
und so weiter.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie so ein Passwort hast, 123, ist das natürlich recht simpel zu hacken.
Das beste Passwort 123456, das wissen wir alle.
Das ist das verbreitetste Passwort und was verbreitet ist, kann nicht schlecht sein.
Man könnte sozusagen sagen, ein Best Practice Passwort.
123456.
Ich habe extra ein Passwort genommen, wo selbst Instagram sagt, das ist...
Zeig mal her, 1234567819111213, ja das ist okay.
Sehr sicher.
Was ich nicht gemacht habe, ist eine Zwei-Stufen-Authentifizierung.
Das ganze lief dann auch natürlich alles mit Fake-Daten und so weiter.
Aber dieses...
Okay, Zwei-Factor-Authentifizierung, das wäre tatsächlich interessant gewesen mit Zwei-Factor-Authentifizierung jetzt.
Das Passwort habe ich im Endeffekt eingestellt, habe nur die URL genommen, den Hackern geschickt
und dann kam einfach nur noch zurück, okay, thanks.
Ja, momentan ist Wochenende, es kann also sein, dass wir erst morgen anfangen dran zu arbeiten.
Die Hacker-Mens haben auch vor, verstehe ich.
Work-Life-Balance ist wichtig.
Und das war's.
Okay, zwei Wochen sind seitdem vergangen und bevor ich euch jetzt gleich das Ergebnis zeige,
nochmal ganz kurz an dieser Stelle etwas zum Rechnen.
Schauen wir also mal, ob wir uns hier wirklich strafbar gemacht haben,
denn tatsächlich ist relativ eindeutig, wie hier vorgegangen wurde.
Wenn ich meine eigenen Profile hacke, dann kommt es darauf an, wie der Hack genau funktioniert.
Wenn man nur irgendwie das Passwort errät und dazu technische Hilfsmittel verwendet
und nicht auf irgendwelche zugangsgesicherten Daten von Meta oder Google zugreift, dann ist das straflos,
denn dann werden nur die Daten des Social-Media-Profils zugegriffen
und man hat dazu eine rechtfertigende Einwilligung.
Anders wäre es allerdings, wenn man auf das Betriebssystem von Meta oder Google zugreift.
Hier kommen je nach technischem Vorgehen wieder die ganzen Hacking-Stars.
Ja, das kann ich mir an der Stelle nicht vorstellen.
So, jetzt aber zum Mailverlauf.
Also, am 21. schrieben die Hacker, sie wollten nochmal Informationen haben, was sie denn genau machen sollen.
Ich habe dann irgendwie so überlegt, vielleicht ist es cool, wenn sie das Profilbild ändern,
weil dann könnte man so aktualisieren, auch für dieses Video.
Da ist ja irgendwie so ein Profilbild von einem Clown oder sowas
und dann wüsste man, okay, der Hack ist gehackt.
So, daraufhin schrieben sie mir aber am 22., dass das komplett unsinnig sei
und ich das ja selber machen könne, wenn sie das PV ändern.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, das hat mich ein bisschen verwirrt, weil vorher hatten sie ja genau das angeboten.
Sie haben gesagt, entweder machen wir was mit dem...
Sie haben gesagt, entweder machen wir was mit dem Hack oder wir hacken den...
Die haben wahrscheinlich erwartet, dass er irgendwas etwas Anspruchsvolleres sagt, als das Bild zu ändern.
Das du sozusagen hinzugefasst hast.
So nach dem Motto, erschleicht euch jetzt mal über dieses Profil noch irgendwie XY oder so.
Nicht change das Profilbild.
Wahrscheinlich haben die etwas Advance erwartet, was sie damit machen sollen.
Ich hab trotzdem relativ simpel geantwortet, weil ich wollte nicht noch mehr irgendwie Diskussion.
Meinte, okay, ihr habt recht, ich mach alles selber, ich brauch einfach nur das Passwort.
Und dann hörte ich bis zum 25. erst mal nix.
Und das war schon ungewöhnlich, weil eigentlich haben die immer nur ein bis zwei Tage gebraucht.
Und ich hab dann einfach mal nachgefragt, hab gesagt, hey, wie sieht's eigentlich aus?
Am 27. schrieben sie dann...
Moment, Geld zurück, Garantie. Die haben zu Lager gebraucht.
Wir dachten, du gibst uns noch mehr Infos, ja, und ob das Target und die Intention immer noch gleich sind.
Ich dachte so, ja, klar, ich hab ja nur einen Insta-Target geschrieben und ich wollte das Passwort.
Also, da gibt's ja gar nicht so viel Spielraum.
Hab dann aber trotzdem relativ freundlich zurückgeschrieben, gesagt, ja, wie gesagt, gleiches Target, bitte einfach nur Passwort.
Und dann wollten sie erst Zeit bis zum Wochenende.
Und dann hab ich noch mal nachgefragt und dann wollten sie 24 Stunden.
Und dann, bam, am 2. sieb, bam, am Freitag um 19.31 Uhr, perfektes Timing für das Fazit für das Video hier, schicken sie mir ein Passwort.
Ich sitz am Rechner, recorde das Ganze mit UBS, wollte das direkt hier einfügen, geb das Passwort ein und es ist inkorrekt.
Und ich hab innerhalb von zwei Minuten zurückgeschrieben, meinte so, hä, das Passwort geht nicht.
Bin dann in den Account rein, hab geguckt, ist irgendwas passiert, keine Attempts.
Wir hatten noch nur einen einzigen Follow, also einen Dude, der uns wirklich da gefolgt ist.
Das Passwort funktioniert hier nicht und augenscheinlich hatten die auch gar nichts gemacht.
So, daraufhin schrieben die dann, hey, hast du denn auch einen VPN benutzt, keine Ahnung wofür einen VPN.
Und sagten mir dann sogar noch, sie wollten mich nicht blamen, ja, aber wollten einfach nur mal nachhaken.
Ja, und das war der Moment, wo wir ehrlich gesagt gar nichts mehr gecheckt haben.
Ich mein, die hatten unsere 300 Dollar, die haben nicht nach mehr Geld gefragt, aber trotzdem war das alles irgendwie nur, ja, weiß ich nicht, Zeitschinderei.
Ich hab es wahrscheinlich hingekriegt.
Sinnlosen Chats, Passwort ist falsch, sie haben augenscheinlich nichts gemacht, wofür das Ganze?
Also warum uns sozusagen hinhalten?
Ich hab dann den lieben Morphoys gefragt, Grüße geben.
Vielleicht sind das irgendwelche indischen Microsoft Gold-Support-Mitarbeiter.
Gerade im Urlaub und der hat mir ein Video aufgenommen, gibt es eine Möglichkeit, dass sie mir echt einen PV schicken, ohne dass ich das als Owner sozusagen mitbekomme.
Und das ist sein Video.
Also eigentlich gibt es drei Möglichkeiten, wie man einen Instagram-Account hacken kann.
Die erste Möglichkeit ist allerdings ziemlich unwahrscheinlich, würde ich behaupten.
Und zwar, die Hacker könnten Instagram-Server direkt angreifen und dort eine Schwachstelle finden.
Eher nicht.
Damit die Server eindringen und quasi voll Zugriff auf Instagram haben.
Glaub aber nicht, dass deine Hacker das wirklich können.
Die zweite Möglichkeit ist ein bisschen wahrscheinlicher, aber immer noch sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Das wäre einmal das Brutforcen von so einem Account.
Auch nicht.
Das bedeutet einfach wirklich jedes Passwort bei dem Account online einfach aus.
Das ist allerdings ein sehr zeitaufwändiger Prozess, vor allem, wenn das Passwort ein bisschen kompliziert ist.
Das Passwort, das war, glaube ich, was? 18 Stellen, da hast du was zu tun.
... ist und deswegen...
Hey, Quiacra, die hart, danke für den Sub.
Die einfachste Möglichkeit wäre Social Engineering.
Das heißt, die Hacker werden eine E-Mail schicken an das Opfer, in dem Fall vielleicht dich.
Und dort dann versuchen, darüber das Opfer dazu zu bewegen, sein Passwort einfach freiwillig anzugeben.
So, und jetzt kommt's.
Ich sitze am Fazit dieses Videos, mache das Skript.
Wollte sagen, hey, keine Ahnung, worum die uns hinhalten, aber es ist anscheinend Scam.
Und wollte noch mal ganz kurz Social Engineering erklären.
Da kam ich auf die Idee, ich könnte ja mal in die Mail von Franjo Beutelin schauen.
Franjo Beutelin at web.de.
Bin also einfach mal reingegangen und habe tatsächlich eine Fishing-Mail.
Ich klicke...
Na toll.
Das ist alles, oder wie?
Obvious.
Es ging dann irgendwie um einen Account, der gemeldet wurde und ich musste wieder herstellen, blablabla.
Ich gebe also diese ganzen Daten.
Lass mich raten, er wurde gar nicht gehackt, oder?
Nein, natürlich schon ein komisches Gefühl dabei, weil ich...
Ach so, er tut jetzt so, er tut jetzt so als ob, okay.
Er weiß ja, was jetzt gleich passiert.
Ja, Passwort sagt er beim ersten Mal immer incorrect.
Das haben die übrigens extra so gebaut.
Ich hab's nämlich mehrere Male probiert, weil die sicherstellen wollen, dass man auch das Richtige eingibt.
Schicke ab, ja, keine Zwei-Stufen-Authentifizierung.
Und er sagt, ey, bloß nichts ändern, jetzt bist du wirklich im Prozess.
Und ich weiß genau, was ihr jetzt denkt.
Weil wir haben genau das Gleiche gedacht und haben einfach nur gewartet, dass die Hacker sich wieder melden.
Nur diese Mail, die ist bis heute nicht da.
Das heißt, der Ack war innerhalb von sechs Minuten weg.
Türkei hat sich eingeloggt, E-Mail-Adresse geändert, aber keine Ahnung, wer dahinter steckt.
Sind es jetzt die Hacker, die irgendwann auch auf mich zukommen und sagen, ja, wir haben jetzt das Passwort.
Vielleicht schicken sie sogar einen Screenshot oder so, dass sie im Ack sind und wollen mehr Geld.
Schicken sie mir einfach so das Ganze.
Oder war das eine komplett dritte Instanz, die mit diesen Hackern jetzt gar nichts zu tun hat?
Aber das Ganze ließ uns gar keine Ruhe...
Aber da ist jetzt nichts Großartiges, Hackerisches dabei, ja?
Wir haben also mal diese Bitcoin-Adresse genommen, wo wir selber die 300 Dollar hinüberwiesen haben.
Und wir blenden euch die auch mal ein, wer da also mal so ein bisschen Schleuschen...
Und mit zwei Fakten oder Defizitiven hätte es schon mal definitiv nicht funktioniert an der Stelle.
Ich habe da noch mal bei GMX einen weiteren Fake erstellt, habe die angeschrieben, die Mail hatte ich ja von denen.
Und habe einfach mal einen komplett anderen Namen genannt.
Einfach gesagt, ey, ich habe euren Kontakt von XY, den es einfach gar nicht gibt.
Und ich bin so und so und das ist auch mein Username.
Daraufhin kam von denen aber sofort eine Mail zurück, dass sie gesagt haben, ne, also den Ben Doerr kennen wir nicht.
Und sagt noch mal ganz genau, in welchem Forum ist welcher Username?
Das heißt, diese Kontaktanfrage oder diese Aufnahmen mit denen nehmen wir halt schon relativ ernst.
Ja, und jetzt kommen wir zu dem Part, der tatsächlich nicht zum Experiment gehörte.
Denn wir haben auch keinen Zugriff mehr auf Stefan Weber von unserem letzten Video.
Der war nämlich auf meinem zweiten Handy im gleichen Schlüsselbund.
Und auch über diesen Account haben die Hacker jetzt den Zugriff.
Auch da bekam ich nämlich eine Mail.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon mal selber hattet, aber Instagram schickt dann sowas.
Hey, wurde geändert.
In welchem Schlüsselbund? Hä?
In welche Mail?
Und dann kannst du da draufdrücken und sozusagen den Akt securen.
Hab ich gemacht, aber dann kommt eben, Seite kann nicht angezeigt werden.
Das heißt, tatsächlich haben wir jetzt keine Möglichkeit mehr, Daniel Beutlin und Stefan Weber zurückzubekommen.
Außer man macht das irgendwie über Instagram jetzt.
Kleiner Einschub an dieser Stelle, also erstmal natürlich eine Dummheit.
Aber den Zusammenhang zwischen den zwei Accounts habe ich jetzt nicht gecheckt.
Das gleiche Passwort zu haben, war für mich irgendwie leichter mit den Fakes.
Aber wir haben trotzdem nochmal drüber nachgedacht.
Ach so, beide Accounts hatten das gleiche Passwort. Ach so.
Bei dieser Instagram Mail.
Und wir glauben, das liegt daran, dass die die Namen geändert hat.
Und dadurch sozusagen die ID oben nicht mehr stimmte.
Und deshalb diese Seite kann nicht angezeigt kommen.
Keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt, aber das wäre auf jeden Fall eine leichte Möglichkeit,
tatsächlich Leuten Accounts sofort zu klauen.
Ja, das war's an dieser Stelle mit dem Video.
Schreibt gerne in die Kommentare.
Naja, also...
Äh...
Ja...
Okay.
Es war nicht so schlimm, wie ich mir das gedacht habe.
Ich dachte, Wunder, was da jetzt für ein Video kommt.
Aber wirklich...
So inhaltlich Substanz hat es jetzt auch nicht gehabt, weil...
Was soll uns das jetzt sagen?
Es ist aber... Es hat mir da eine Sache bestätigt.
Die ich auch schon oft in Videos gesagt habe.
Weil die Leute teilweise so irrationale Angst davor haben.
Oh, hilf, ich kann gehackt werden.
Also, man kann davon ausgehen, dass die ganzen Login-Systeme, sei es jetzt von Microsoft für den Microsoft-Account,
Google-Accounts...
Was weiß ich, Facebook-Logins und so.
Dass die an sich keine bekannten, ähm...
Großartigen Sicherheitsprobleme haben.
Ich sage nicht, dass die 100% nicht sicher sind, weil die haben bestimmt Probleme.
Aber nichts, was da hergelaufen und nur nach 15 Hacker einfach mal irgendwie auspacken kann und sagt, aha, Login.
So.
Und das heißt, die Leute sind in der Regel immer selbst dran schuld, wenn ihnen was passiert.
Zum größten Teil. Ja, zum größten Teil.
Also sprich, die haben sich irgendwelche Keylogger eingefangen.
Irgendwelche Root-Kits, die deine Session klauen.
Die lassen sich fischen mit irgendwelchen E-Mails.
Und solche Geschichten.
Also, ich würde standardmäßig immer davon ausgehen, wenn ich einen Account verliere,
dass meine Rechner irgendwie verseucht sind oder ich irgendwas verkackt habe.
Nicht, dass Google daran schuld ist, dass ihr Alternifizierungssystem unsicher ist.
Und dass sich sogar das FBI an iPhones, an der iPhone-Verschlüsselung den Finger ausbeißt.
Oder auch bei uns, äh, die Polizei sich die Verschlüsselung an, äh,
also früher zumindest an TrueCripp Festplatten ausbeißt und solche Geschichten sollte.
Und da geht es um etwas krassere Sachen als irgendein Typ auf Instagram.
Da geht es von Terrorismus, organisiertes Verbrechen und alles Mögliche.
Ähm, das ist zumindest schon mal ein Indikator für, dass du nicht einfach sagen kannst,
haha, ich hacke jetzt easy alles innerhalb von 72 Stunden.
Wo hätte ich die E-Mail-Adresse, wo ist das eine gute Frage?
Ja.
Nö.
Ähm, das habe ich hier irgendwo auf, dieses Video, ja.
Das geht aber 37 Minuten, das wollte ich nicht gucken, das ist zu lang.
Es ist tatsächlich, das fand ich auch am interessantesten an dem Video,
dass man halt mal so Kontaktaufnahme, wenn man es dann probiert, sieht und so.
Das fand ich okay, die eigentliche Hacking-Geschichte war halt nicht existent.
Wurde es gestern noch fertig mit dem ganzen, also fertig bin ich nicht,
also es ist nicht alles das, was ich mir da vorstelle gemacht,
aber ich habe das hingekriegt, dass es drei Server automatisch aufbaut,
Loadbalancer, die Server ins Loadbalancing nimmt.
Jaja, das hat soweit funktioniert.
Aber ich habe mir gestern Abend noch etwas Tutorials und Sachen durchgelesen zu diesem Thema
und das ist komplett ein Fass ohne Boden.
Man kann zum Beispiel sogar eigene Ubuntu-Images bauen für die Hetzner Cloud,
dass der Aufbau schneller geht und sowas, das ist das wirkliche, komplettes Fass ohne Boden.
So, was können wir uns als nächstes angucken?
Was können wir uns als nächstes zeigen?
Was hältst du? Keine Ahnung, sagt mir nichts.
Refresh. So, ich habe ein eigenes Video nicht fertig geguckt.
So, was können wir uns als nächstes angucken?
Was verdient ein Bundespolizist?
Das können wir uns angucken, weil das ist tatsächlich ein Beruf,
den würde ich im Leben nicht machen wollen.
Es gibt so ein paar Dinge, die ich nicht machen würde.
Also Alten- und Krankenpfleger ist auf jeden Fall dabei und Polizist auch nicht.
Okay, ehrlich gesagt, es gibt mehr Dinge, die ich nicht machen würde, als Dinge, die ich machen würde,
auch nicht für viel Geld.
Was macht er in der Technikkeller? Von dem haben wir auch schon eine Weile nichts mehr geguckt.
Einfach nur mal für den Fall der Fälle, dass wir nachher noch was brauchen.
So, zeige ich mal her.
Was verdient ein Bundespolizist?
Wahrscheinlich, ich tippe einfach mal drauf, dass es sich nicht lohnt.
Rein von der Kohle her und der Belastung und der Verantwortung und der Anstrengung, die damit verbunden ist.
Und mit den Leuten, wo du dich auseinandersetzen musst.
Erst mal die gute MP5 dabei, das ist das Beste.
Patrouille mit MP5, auf geht's.
So, jetzt haben wir hier wahrscheinlich zu viele Aufenthaltstage.
Immer ein Gehalt sehr gut. Ich kann sehr viel sparen.
Hi, ich bin der Nathan. Ich bin Polizeibeamter bei der Bundespolizei am Münchener Flughafen.
Und heute zeige ich euch meinen Tag.
Laut genug.
Wir bewegen uns jetzt Richtung Wache, das ist Bereich B bei uns.
Mein Einsatzgebiet beschränkt sich auf Terminal 1.
Die Musik im Hintergrund. Schau mal, was heute auf uns zukommt.
Es geht schon los, ja.
Stempel-Uhr. Morgen, Christoph.
Hier ist immer die erste Anlaufstelle. Erst mal Taschen abstellen.
Gut, also ich werde jetzt das Funkgerät empfangen.
Mit mir auch mitbekommen, was hier so los ist.
Und stempeln, ein- und ausreißen.
Stempel-Test, oder?
Genau, Stempel-Test. Also das wäre tatsächlich fatal, wenn wir falsch stempeln würden.
Beziehungsweise dann die Pässe mit einem falschen Datum oder sowas.
Das wäre blöd. Also nicht für ihn, aber für den Typ, dem der Pass gehört.
Gut, dann schauen wir auf den Plan.
Chatter ist bestimmt der richtige Gigachatter-Typ.
Und unser Beruf ist sehr gefährlich.
Wirklich viele, egal welche Altersklasse, haben gerne mal ein Messer stecken.
Du weißt halt nie, wie die Person tickt.
Die Regel hast du im Laufe des Tages immer andere Aufgaben.
Da gehst du mal auf Streife, da machst du mal die Einreise.
Der erste Auftrag ist eine Einreise um in einer halben Stunde circa.
Aus Doha.
Ist Doha nicht die Battlefield Map?
Die Battlefield 2042 Map, wo nichts außer Sanddünen sind und drei Häuser.
Und die Map übelst kacke ist.
Ist das nicht die... Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Map heißt.
Das ist doch Indoor.
Das ist noch ganz ruhig, aber das wird später...
Warum haben wir eigentlich Untertitel an?
...in ein paar Minuten gleich hier richtig voll werden.
Guten Morgen.
Er legt mir natürlich dann seinen Reisepass vor.
Ich schau erstmal, ob das die Person ist.
Ist das überhaupt?
Dann geht es dann die Befragung los.
Also ich frage, was machen Sie in Deutschland?
Die Musik ist übelst nervös im Hintergrund.
Ich meine, das passiert ja gerade nichts.
Und wie die sich die Reise finanzieren.
Vielleicht hat die Person ja Urlaubsgeld angespart und kann auch die Besprechung vorlegen.
Wenn die Person mir dann Antworten geben kann, dann passt das für mich soweit.
Jetzt kommen jetzt die Dublin zuerst, dann eine Eastmere und Antalya kommt dann auch noch zum Schluss.
Also drei Maschinen insgesamt.
Es kann nicht sein, dass die Person mit dem Reisepass in Deutschland ist.
Und keine Pause hat.
Ich hatte in der Familie in Thailand damals einen Onkel, der bei der Polizei war.
Nach dem Dienst noch in seiner Uniform und seiner Waffe hat er sich zugesetzt und gegessen.
Man muss den ganzen Tag mit Leuten reden.
Das würde mich schon mal nerven.
Ganz faszinierend.
Dann hat sich das Ganze bis hierhin erledigt.
Weil ich hatte nur einen thailändischen Pass, als ich nach Deutschland gekommen bin.
Und erst mit einem deutschen Pass hatte ich dann die Möglichkeit.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, jetzt erfülle ich mal meinen Traum und bewerbe mich mal bei der Polizei.
Für mich ist es wichtig, dass ich das auch dann erkenne, wenn mich jemand anlügt oder mir irgendwas vorgaukelt.
Mit Erfahrung erkennst du an Körperhaltung, an der Aussprache.
Ist die Person nervös beim Reden?
Zittern die sogar?
Was ist der Grund?
Also sprich, wenn einer vor dem steht, so, das merkt er.
Willst du hier in Deutschland bleiben?
Ich werde ein Praktikum machen.
Sie wollen ein Praktikum machen?
Ich bleibe für drei Monate.
Okay.
Einfach zu sagen, ich habe ein Praktikum hier, kann ich ja nicht so glauben.
Er muss mir Dinge vorlegen.
Haben Sie eine Einladung?
Das Praktikum?
Ja, ich habe eine Einladung.
Können Sie mir zeigen?
In dem Fall hat er eine Bestätigung von der Bundesagentur für Arbeit.
Da steht drin, was er hier macht.
Er hat sogar einen Vertrag.
Das sieht ganz vernünftig aus, was er mir vorlegt.
Und für mich war klar, dass die Person mir die Wahrheit gesagt hat.
Und somit durfte er dann auch einreisen.
Was wirst du in den Wissert gehen?
Nur in Munich?
In den Berchtesgaden.
Berchtesgaden, okay.
Es ist sehr schön dort.
Berchtesgaden.
Weißt du gar nicht, wo Berchtesgaden ist, Alter?
Und schon haben wir Mittag, ne?
Ja, in Bayern.
Das hätte ich mir gedacht.
Das ist der Flughafen in München.
Um die Idee, dass es in Bayern ist, wäre ich auch noch gekommen.
Ich habe jetzt eine halbe Stunde die Ausreise.
Eine halbe Stunde habe ich noch Zeit.
Dann hole ich mir noch ein Brötchen von der Edeka.
Das geht einfach mal mit.
Gerade der Bäckerl auf vorne ist sehr teuer.
Ich bin ein Tourist, der nach Deutschland kommt.
Der kennt halt nur Brezel vielleicht.
Und natürlich will er Brezel.
Dann würde ich auch ein bisschen mehr für eine Brezel verlangen.
Dann würde ich auch ein bisschen mehr Brezel verlangen.
Wahrscheinlich ist das Brötchen mega teuer.
Es ist ein Brötchen mit einem Stück Wurst drauf.
Und kostet wahrscheinlich 4 Euro.
Wir gehen jetzt in die grenzpolizeiliche Ausreisekontrolle.
Jetzt genau anders um die Frage, was sie in Deutschland gemacht haben.
Wie lange sie aufhalten können.
Wenn es ein bisschen widersprüchliche Angaben gibt,
weiterhandeln. Hallo, just a moment please. All right? Hallo.
Did you come from war? From in since February. And now what's your
destination? Where are you going now? What? Where are you going now?
To Atlanta? Ja. So, jetzt haben wir hier wahrscheinlich. Die Musik, Alter. Viele Aufenthalts-Tage.
Warte mal. 22. Genau. Also, so gesehen werde jetzt. Oh, vielleicht war sie drei Stunden zu
lang da. Das geht ja nicht. 20 Tage zu hier. Oh, das ist natürlich schon einiges. Okay, war, dass sie sich
länger als 90 Tage sie hier aufgehalten hat. Allerdings war die vom Krieg. Muss ich mal kurz mit der
Wache abklären. Are you going to return to Germany? Are you going to return to Germany after Atlanta?
Back to Ukraine? Not Germany again? No? Okay. Alex, hier ist Nathan. Hi. Du, ich habe hier eine Ukrainerin, die
reist jetzt nach Atlanta. Wie ist es bei Ukraine? Wie anzeigen wir die trotzdem jetzt noch? Die hat
gerade 25.02. und die ist vom Krieg geflohen, hat sie gesagt. Ja. Danke dir. Ciao. Genau. Also, strafrechtlich.
Na ja, die hat streng genommen, hat die nicht gesagt, sie ist vom Krieg geflohen. Er hat sie
gefragt, ob sie aus dem Kriegsgebiet kommt und sie hat gesagt, ja. Die hätte wahrscheinlich zu
viele gesagt, ja, wenn es nicht stimmt. Es gibt eine Übergangsregelung jetzt bei den Ukrainer.
Aufgrund ihrer Flüchtlings-Eigenschaft ist sie straffrei geblieben. Ja, ist auch gut so. Ist ja kein
was passiert irgendwo. Einreißen, um nicht nur Urlaub zu machen, aber wenn ich jemand kontrolliere
und frage, was machen sie in Deutschland oder warum waren sie in Deutschland? Ja, ich habe
jemand beerdigt. Das ist dann für mich dann persönlich auch schwierig. Ich bin ja auch
ein bisschen emotional. Wir schauen, ob sich Personen sich verdächtlich verhalten und wir
schauen, dass keine Gegenstände hier rumliegen. Ich muss jetzt mal was sagen. Wisst ihr, worüber
ich echt froh bin, dass wir in Deutschland solche Polizisten haben und nicht die Kekona-Polizei.
Ich stelle zum Beispiel jetzt vor uns eine Gefahr da. Also wir wissen nicht, was in dem Koffer drin ist. Kann
ein Sprengstoff sein. Erstmal direkt den Koffer mit der MP5 kontrollieren auf geht's. Naja gut,
du weißt nie, was abgeht am Flughafen. Ich würde tatsächlich interessieren, wie viel übrig bleibt,
weil ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass du auch nicht so viel Steuern bezahlen musst als Beamter oder
als Polizist. Lass mal kurz überlegen. Also für das Geld würde ich das nett machen,
davon abgesehen. Ich könnte das auch, ich würde das auch gar nicht machen. Ich würde mir das
doppelte bezahlen, aber so reich wirst du davon jetzt nicht. Ich habe mich am Anfang des Jahres
dazu entschieden, mein Auto zu verkaufen. Meins stand einfach nur so rum. Ich hatte ein Audi A4,
war persönlich mein Wunschauto damals. Hat auch ein bisschen weh getan, dass ich das Auto hergeben
musste. Habe es damals für 26.000 Euro gekauft und habe es tatsächlich für 22.000 nach drei Jahren
wieder verkauft. Kommt, Brian. Und er ist in München. Das stimmt auch noch dabei. München ist
auch noch teuer. Momentan spare ich sehr viel Geld, um in dem Heimatland meiner Mutter mal
ein Ferienhaus zu kaufen auf eine schöne Insel. Hast du schon eine Insel im Blick? Ja, das kostet
mir tatsächlich. Schließe ich noch meine Waffe weg und dann komme ich in Zivil wieder. Die Wohnung
kostet jetzt 850 Euro warm. Wir teilen uns gerechter auf, weil meine Freundin weniger verdient
als ich. Am liebsten würde ich mich jetzt auch dahinlegen jetzt und ein bisschen entspannen,
aber ich habe heute ja noch was vor. Wir fangen uns dann nach Halbeck-Moos. Da treffe ich mich
jetzt mit meinen Arbeitskollegen. Wir haben ein Hobby-Volleyball-Team. Ich hatte Eltern,
die selbst keinen guten Schulabschluss haben. Also mittelmäßig. Also meine Mama konnte damals,
als ich nach Deutschland auch kam. Man muss die Waffe nicht auf der Arbeit, weil er mit dem Zug
heimfährt, hat er noch gesagt. Und wenn er im Zug ist, muss er da bei Straftaten auch einschreiten.
Ich kenne das von uns. Bei uns sind auch öfters, also bei mir hier, sind auch öfters im Zug
Polizisten mit Pistole. Sie ist auch nicht so viel Deutsch und sie konnte mir dementsprechend
auch nicht bei den Hausaufgaben helfen. Ich hatte zum Glück gute Nachbarn, gute Freunde,
die geholfen haben. Ich hatte aber auch die Wille dazu. Also ich wollte was erreichen.
Was geht mit der Musik ab jetzt? Jetzt bin ich genau da gelandet, wo ich sein sollte. Ich verdiene
gut. Es ist mein Traumberuf, schon immer als Kind. Und deswegen bin ich tatsächlich auf mich selbst
stolz. Das ist doch schön. Kann er auch. Ist das Toss-Musik? Ich hoffe vielleicht, dass es Toss-Musik
ist. Toss, Toss, Toss. Ich hoffe, das hat euch gefallen. Wenn ihr auch mal mitmachen wollt,
dann bewerbt euch unter lohntsichdasmpa.de und hier und hier. Solange ich mit der MP5 durch den
Zug fährt, gibt es weitere Videos. Tschau, machts gut. Also die Videos gucke ich immer ganz gerne.
Hast du eine Switch? Ja, habe ich. Aber ich habe für die Switch irgendwie drei Games oder so und
spiele sie so gut wie die Switch. Ich war dumm, dass ich mir die Switch gekauft habe. Pepega.
Hast du die Folge mit dem Entwickler gesehen? Haben die eine neue?
Haben die eine neue? Nee, gell? Das kennen wir schon. Das kennen wir nicht. Das da meinst du,
das haben wir geguckt, ja. Ja, ja, das haben wir geguckt. Das kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Der Senior Dev nach zwei Jahren war das. Jaja, das haben wir geguckt. Die dunkle Wahrheit über
Fanta. Unter Hitler geht da nichts anscheinend. Wir testen den 36 Kern AliExpress Gaming PC.
Das ist doch auch wieder G-Bade Video, oder? Das ist doch bestimmt G-Bade. Warum ist denn der PC so
schepp? Alles zu funktionieren. Heute werden wir den PC testen. Wir werden herausfinden,
was der so auf dem Kasten hat, ob wirklich das drin ist. Mich hätte vor allem interessiert,
wie lange hat der Versand gedauert aktuell? Steht und das werden wir jetzt herausfinden.
Immerhin nicht auf Wish bestellt, weil ganz im Ernst jeder, der noch irgendwie ein bisschen
bei Verstand ist, kann einfach AliExpress direkt bestellen, anstatt sich den Wish Scam zu geben.
Das Video wird euch präsentiert vom Gaming Webbrowser. Wo wir dabei sind. OperatiX spampt mich
auch die ganze Zeit voll, ob wir nicht wieder Cooperation machen wollen. Und dabei habe ich
schon denen mal geschrieben, ja machen wir. Und dann hatten wir uns auch auf irgendwas geeinigt.
Und dann wollten sie von mir, dass ich irgendwie... Ich kriege das gar nicht mehr zusammen,
wie das war mit OperatiX. Ich sollte irgendwas zeigen und irgendwie das voll abfeiern oder so.
Da habe ich gesagt, ich habe OperatiX mal vor einer Weile ausprobiert und ich war nicht so überzeugt.
Dann haben die gesagt, ach nee, dann lassen wir das lieber, wie sie machen. Am liebsten was mit
Leuten zusammen, die ihr Produkt auch geil finden. Und seitdem dachte ich, jetzt ist erledigt,
aber die spammen mich trotzdem weiter voll. Ansonsten mache ich OperatiX Werbung,
so nach dem Motto, dieses Video ist gesponsert von OperatiX. OperatiX ist der Nummer 1 Gaming
Browser. Ihr könnt OperatiX hier und hier downloaden und die RGB-Unterstützung ist ganz toll.
Next. Das kann ich machen, da habe ich keine Schmerzen mit.
...eigene Profile für verschiedene Zwecke anlegen. Wenn dein PC mal nicht flüssig läuft,
dann verwende einfach den Potato-Modus, um ohne Leistungsverlust zu surfen. Solltest du etwas
Privatsphäre gebrauchen, dann empfiehlt er sich den Modus Rogue zu wählen. Beim Schließen des
Browsers werden alle deine Spuren verwischt. Ja Wondershare hatte mich auch schon mal gefragt.
Findest du einen echt genialen Überblick über Game-Releases, Gratis-Spiele und die
neuesten News rund ums Thema Gaming? Durch den Klick in die oberre rechte Ecke kommt ihr zum
Punkt Einfache Einrichtung. Also solange ich dieses Video hier nicht selbst aufnehmen muss,
wie ich da drin rumklicke, ist alles gut. Kannst du dir den Browser ganz nach deinem Vorlieben
individuell anpassen? Wähle eins der vielen vorgefertigten Designs oder pass einfach jede
Farbe so an, wie du es gerne haben möchtest. Ein weiteres neues echt geniales Feature ist die
Möglichkeit Seiten ohne Dark Mode in den Dark Mode zu forsen und als Perfekt. Das gab es ja noch nie.
Die erste Ergänzung gibt's Oprah GX jetzt auch als Mobile-Version. Wenn du deine Gaming-Erfahrung,
also gratis vollenden möchtest, dann findest du alle Infos und den... Wenn du auch deine
Gaming-Erfahrung gratis vollenden möchtest. Okay, das ist definitiv ein Satz, der außer
irgendeinem Marketing-Cop niemand so über die Lippen kommen würde. Wenn du deine Gaming...
Das ist eins zu eins abgelesen aus irgendeinem Briefing 100 Pro. Der Browser, was da mit Gaming
zu tun hat, ehrlich gesagt gar nichts. Warum es Gaming heißt ist, die haben RGB-Unterstützung
und du kannst das ergeblich in irgendeinen Modus versetzen, wo es weniger RAM braucht und so was.
Also eigentlich hat es da... Ist Blödsinn. Also der Sinn und Zweck erschließt sich mir nicht,
aber okay, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, ich sollte denen mal antworten. So ein Placement kann ich
auch machen. Denk unten in der Videobeschreibung. Wir wissen ja, unser Netzteil ist ein bisschen
zickig, deswegen hoffe ich, dass der PC auch wieder angeht und nicht in der Zwischenzeit sich
wieder anders überlegt hat. Hier ist er, unser externer Anschalter. Es sieht nicht gut aus,
wir haben kein Bild und wir haben einen Boot-Postcode B7. Keine Ahnung, was er bedeutet und ich habe
schon mal ins Handbuch vorher geschaut, ob wir da irgendwelche Hinweise auf irgendwas bekommen
könnten. In dem Handbuch steht gar nichts. Was ist denn für Hardware drinne in dem 36-Kern
AliExpress-Rechner? Deswegen müssen wir das jetzt irgendwie selber rausfinden, was hier nicht
funktioniert. Ich mache den einfach noch mal aus und schalte ihn noch mal an. Das Gehäuse sieht
irgendwie kacke aus, oder? Das ist Schäpp, das hat keinerlei Staubschutz, also das ist im Prinzip
einfach nur ein Metallkiste aus Resteteilen oder so. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel er gekostet hat,
vielleicht kriegen wir noch was erzählt.
Wir gehen mal ein bisschen vor. Das ist der RAM-Riegel. Ach, die RGB-Beleuchtung für den RAM,
die braucht extra Stromanschlüsse oder was? Das ist ja die sinnloseste RGB-Beleuchtung aller
Zeiten, Alter. Ich meine RAM RGB-Beleuchtung ist schon bescheuert, aber die dann auch noch
ein extra Stromanschluss braucht, also das ist ja komplett unsinnig. Die Maus, die Maus ist cool.
Pro CPU wegen Quad-Channel sind ja Server-CPUs und wir haben die jetzt immer in Channel 1 und 3 sind
die drin und so ist die einzige Konfiguration, wie wir den PC zum Starten bekommen haben. Keine
Ahnung, wieso wir das letzte Mal ein Bild bekommen haben und heute auf einmal irgendwie
und wir haben unser BIOS. Zumindest werden die vollen 32 GB RAM erkannt. Und was ist für
ein Mainboard? Zeig her. Ah, Huan Shan Ji X990, also irgendein Intel-Ding. Wirkt schon mal sehr
vertrauenserwürdig hier. Sind ja zwei CPUs zugeordnet, also gehe ich mir davon aus, dass auch beide CPUs
erkannt werden. Sind da zwei CPUs drin? Was denn für welche? Sieht schon mal ganz gut aus, 40 Grad beides.
Was ist es denn? Sieht man was es ist? Intel-Lauten steht es. Xeon, 1, 2, 9, 9, Xeon 2, 6, 9, 9, was?
Was? So was der da?
Was? Von 2014? Ach du Scheiße! Okay, Aliexpress Shit, alles klar.
Alles der CPU, wo sind wir? Ah, ich find das Video nicht mehr, Leute. Der CPU von 2014, man.
Und hier ist er. Intel Xeon E5 2699 V3 mit jeweils 18 Kernen. Also ist auf jeden Fall das drin,
was drauf steht und ich hoffe auch, dass Windows die beiden erkennen wird.
Klar.
Gut, also jetzt brauch ich ne Maus.
Aber Windows 11 läuft da drauf bestimmt nicht mehr.
Ihr seid natürlich mal wieder so clever und habt rausgepumpten. Der Empfänger befindet sich hier im
Batteriefach drin. Die Maus funktioniert auf jeden Fall. Ich kann hier im Windows Setup rumklicken.
Setup wird gestartet. Product Key haben wir natürlich keinen. Wegen In-Sy-Modus, ihr wisst Bescheid.
Nur bei Windows 10 Pro haben wir Moody's.
Der war gut. In-Sy-Modus.
Und wir haben zwei CPUs, würde uns jetzt nicht viel bringen, Windows 10 Home zu installieren.
Installieren wir den Bums mal und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder.
Windows ist installiert. Ab und zu kommt hier von dem PC mal ein leichtes Klackern,
aber ansonsten hat alles geklappt. Ich hätte gesagt, wir schauen direkt mal rein in den
Windows Task Manager. Das könnte vielleicht ganz interessant sein, denn hier, wie ihr sehen könnt,
werden jede Menge CPU-Cores angezeigt. Ich glaube, ich hatte noch nie einen PC,
auf dem so viele Kerne zu sehen waren. Wie ihr sehen könnt, hier auch beide Sockets werden
angezeigt. 36 Kerne, 72 Threads. Kann sich auf jeden Fall sehen lassen. Und was diese 72 Threads
in Cinebench drauf haben, das werden wir uns jetzt anschauen. Zack, in Cinebench rein.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, allein schon, weil selbst wenn die CPU von 2014 ist, Cinebench ist besser
parallelisieren kannst du kaum noch. Das wird ein ganz gutes Ergebnis kriegen, keine Frage.
Aber für Games wird er trotzdem nicht wahnsinnig gut sein.
Aber wenn die AVX und solche Geschichten machen, dann ist er wieder nicht so der Wahnsinn. Das
konnten die damals noch nicht. Er hat aber auch nur halb so viele Kerne. Nee, weniger. Was haben
die 12 Kerne aktuell? Der hat auch dreimal weniger Kerne. Also sieht man, die CPUs selber sind schon
deutlich effektiver geworden. Wie viele Kerne haben die? 12? 8? Was hatten denn in 16? Ja,
dann hat er quasi halb so viele. Okay, der Chat erzählt wieder sonst was. Ich muss jetzt gucken,
wie viele Kerne das Ding hat. 16. Naja, bisschen weniger als halb so viel. Da sieht man schon,
es ist schon deutlich effizienter geworden. Naja, kann man so sagen. Für Games ist es auf
jeden Fall nicht gut. Single Core ist für den Arsch.
Ich meine, wenn man sowas haben will, kann man sich auch künstlich auf eBay kaufen. Also
alte Server-Hardware oder sowas mit vielen CPUs, das kostet auch nicht die Welt auf eBay. Das
willst du halt nicht haben, wegen Krach und Stromverbrauch, aber okay. Workstation hängt
halt davon ab, was du machst. Also wenn du Videos encodes, ist das glaube ich ganz okay. Also je nach
dem, was du für ein Codec verwendest. Wenn du die schön multithreading kannst, ja, bestimmt. Wenn
du was hast, was eher die 1, 2, 3, 4 Kern-Performance braucht und dafür halt mehr Wumms pro Kern,
ist es eher nicht so gut. Ja, Blender ist wahrscheinlich wunderbar. Vermute ich mal. Blender
kann ich mir vorstellen, ist gut. Wobei ich mir bei Blender nicht sicher bin, was die als Mindest-CPU,
ob die irgendwelche AVX-Sätze oder so Befehlssätze brauchen. Weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Der Turbo-Takt sind 3,6 Gigahertz. Dann schauen wir gleich mal,
auf wie viel die Kerne takten, wenn wir so einen Multi-Qual-Test anmachen. Einige Kerne gehen auf
2,8 und bei der anderen CPU sind es auch 2,8. Der Test ist halt relativ schnell fertig.
Stromverbrauch wäre halt mal was. Das Ding wird ordentlich Strom ziehen, kann ich euch sagen.
Das ist schon krass dafür, dass wir halt 18 Kerne auf einen Sondai gepackt haben. Das ist schon echt
wild. Wir haben auch einen Temperatursensor auf dem Mainboard selber, auf unserem guten
Guanyin-C-Mainboard. Der zeigt halt einfach stabile minus 125 Grad für die CPU an. Also,
ich glaube nicht, dass das der echte Wert ist. Aber minus 125 Grad kann sich auf jeden Fall auch
sehen lassen. Gut, also Temperaturen passen, Takt passt. Wir gehen jetzt mal in Blender rein und
dann schauen wir uns an, ob dieser PC auch als Workstation taugt. Also, dann rendern wir den
Spaß mal und mal schauen, wo wir da zeitlich rauskommen. Gut, also 83 Sekunden sind unser
Ergebnis. Das ist schon ziemlich schnell. Ja, Rendersachen gehen bestimmt gut. Vergessen,
und zwar das Ganze läuft aktuell nur im Dual-Channel. Der anderen Seite, ich könnte mir
vorstellen, weiß nicht, inwieweit Blender diese Dinger auch mit Grafikkarte rendern kann. Das
dürfte natürlich mal eine ganze Ecke schneller sein. Gut, SSD ist okay. Wie ist denn so der
Stromverbrauch? Der Stromverbrauch würde mich tatsächlich interessieren. Was ist da? Was für
eine Grafikkarte ist da drin? Im Prinzip wird jetzt erstmal nur unsere GTX 1060 5 GB getestet. 10?
Okay, das ist echt nicht der Wahnsinn. Immerhin, was wir auch hier schon sehen können, ist,
dass die GPU schön ausgelastet ist mit 99 bis 100 Prozent und halt die CPU zumindest mal bei
den Benchmarks kein Bottleneck darstellt. Aber gut, ich meine, wir sind mit der 1060 halt auch
nur bei 20. Die Grafikkarte sackt halt auch. Was soll das von Bottlenecken? CPU auf jeden Fall so
stark ausgelastet, dass Afterburner nicht mal lädt. Klassisches Phänomen. So, da ist es das
Ergebnis. Auf jeden Fall Legendary. Kann sich sehen lassen. Grafikscore von 3800 Punkten und
CPUscore von 8100 Punkten. 8100 Punkte, keine besonders krasse Leistung, wie jetzt im Cinebench.
Ja, das liegt halt an der Grafikkarte, ja. Die wird sicher nur daran liegen, dass ihr halt nicht
alle Kerne hier verwendet. Ja, und weil die Grafikkarte sackt. Dann können wir das Ganze
noch vergleichen, online. So, und wo sind wir? Sogar im unteren Fünftel sind wir unterwegs. Auf
jeden Fall sind wir immerhin besser als ein Office Laptop 2020. Na, Wahnsinn. Und ein bisschen hinter
einem ge... ansehendes Benchmark. Wir schauen jetzt... Headset mit Bus Cancellation. Oh nee,
China-Chinesen-Headset, please. Das ist bestimmt krasam. Jetzt natürlich für CSGO. Leider
funktioniert ja MSI Afterburner nicht mehr in CSGO. Deswegen haben wir nur diesen kleinen
FPS-Counter hier. Aber sieht aktuell gar nicht schlecht aus. Also, CS läuft ja auch auf der
Kartoffel. 200 FPS. Schau mal, jetzt hab ich's. Dem hab ich's gezeigt. Aber halt auch mit der
Tastatur, wenn du hier was klickst. Wie sich das anhört. Boah. Also ein Kill muss ich noch machen.
Gut, also. Wir können festhalten, Leute, das Ding ist einfach nur eine absolute CSGO-Maschine,
so wie ich. So zwischen 150 und 250 FPS haben wir eigentlich die ganze Zeit. Toaster-Test ist
bestanden. Das nächste Spiel ist Battlefield 5. Und ich hätte gesagt, wir lassen uns auch mal die
Auslastung von den einzelnen Kernen anzeigen. Das Lustige ist, Afterburner kann nicht mal alle
Threads von einer CPU anzeigen. Tja. Weil eine CPU hat ja 18 Kerne. Das heißt 36 Threads und wir
haben hier nur 32. Trotzdem mal interessant zu sehen, wie viele von den Threads überhaupt
ausgelastet werden können, wenn ich hier so eine Multiplayer-Session starte. Und wir haben 100 FPS.
Was? Es sieht ruckelig aus. Guck mal, oder vielleicht liegt es an der Aufnahme. Das ist auch
interessant, wie die Kerne ausgelastet sind, oder? Ja, das liegt alles an der Grafikkarte. Das ist
jetzt aber, sag mal, da muss man eigentlich von ausgehen, oder? Dass die Grafikkarte das Problem
ist. Theoretisch hättest du in dieses Ding mal eine richtig fette Grafikkarte einbauen müssen und
gucken, was dann die CPU hinkriegt. Zwei Prozent, fünf Prozent, drei Prozent. Und die Sache ist auch,
das ist wahrscheinlich genau die CPU, die aktuell nicht verwendet wird. Aber ich nehme ganz stark an,
dass selbst wenn das jetzt die CPU wäre, dann hätten wir hier nur, keine Ahnung, acht aktive
Kerne oder so und der Rest wäre halt absolut nicht im Gebrauch. Aber dafür und für die relativ
geringe Single-Core-Performance ist die Leistung hier in Battlefield echt nicht schlecht.
Einfach Battlefield zusammengefasst. Er liegt da auf dem Boden auf so einem Stein. Camper.
Camper. Ich glaube, man kann es zusammenfassen. Battlefield 90, mal vergleichen. Das Projekt,
würde ich sagen. Mit einer Sache bin ich natürlich nicht ganz zufrieden und zwar,
dass die RAM-Riegel hier so runter baumeln. Also Stromverbrauch hätte mich echt interessiert,
aber gut. Vielleicht hat er es irgendwo zwischendurch gesagt, wo ich weitergeskippt habe,
kann ja sein. Wirklich. Ach, weiß man ja nicht. Was haben wir denn hier als nächstes? Ach,
crazy, crazy AI-Websites. Okay, zeig her. Ich habe schon mal ein Video geguckt. Die letzten
Empfehlungen in dem Video waren wirklich gut. Deswegen habe ich das Video auch aufgemacht.
Ich dachte beim letzten Video schon, das ist krasse Chibate, aber da waren einige Sachen drin,
die waren wirklich cool. Generating Speech from Text. Das kann ja sogar mein Overlay.
Leute, Generating Speech from Text. Also, das kann ja sogar meine Software.
This first one is from StreamSpeak and you're able to generate English speaking speech from
text or in other words text to speech. Here's what you do. You add your text and I'm going to
copy and paste this sample text. StreamSpeak? Ja, das ist das. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das Plugin
ist, was manche Leute verwenden, wo dann Donations vorgelesen werden, wo die Leute dann irgendwelche
komischen Gatchi-Buzz-Donations vorlesen lassen und denken, sie sind super funny.
You choose the voice and you can choose between a U.S. male, female or one of these other options.
What you do next is scroll down and click on that generate button.
Okay, next. The Image Enlarger, nice. Ist das wieder CSI Zoom? Enhance. Enhance Zoom.
It's called AI Image Enlarger. So here's a demo. To best demonstrate, what I'm going to do is
upload one of my low quality photos and then upload it to AI Image Enlarger. Here's my original
photo so you can see before. I'm going to zoom in so you can see exactly what it looks like.
Quite pixelated, blurry and it's just not in detail. Let's now take it to AI Image Enlarger
to see what it can do. Das probiere ich gleich mal aus. Wenn es was taugt, lasse ich mal ein
Bild von Chico hochrendern. Okay, es hat eine krasse Schärfe. Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie
so ein überdrehter Schärfefilter. Aber es sieht doch deutlich besser aus. Jaja, auf jeden Fall.
Es sieht halt aus wie eine Mischung aus einem super krassen Schärfefilter, der Details dazu erfindet.
Okay, wie heißt das Ding? Das probieren wir jetzt mal mit dem Bild von Chico aus. Also Image Enlarger.
Okay, Chico, wo ist das Bild von Chico? Hier. Nee, nee, nee, nicht das Chico Bild. Hier.
Okay, ihr habt mal ein Bild von Chico. Bild ist wie groß? Ja, das machen wir jetzt auf 4K. Chico auf
4K. Selekt Images. Ja, Chico. Was? Okay, Free Account. Sign Up.
10-Minute-Mail. Auf geht's. Jawoll, die Mail wollte ich schon immer mal haben.
Das Passwort. Okay, Passwort. Sack. Muss mal random irgendwas tippen. Ja, perfekt. Das Passwort.
Excellent. Die wollen, dass die, dass die, die Instagram Hacker hacken können.
Ja, mach ich, mach ich. Wir müssen warten, wir müssen warten, bis die, bis die Mail ankommt.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt einfach das Video weiter, bis die Mail ankommt. Das dauert manchmal ein
bisschen. Es sei denn, es sei denn, die haben es, es sei denn, die haben es geblockt hier. Und das Video
weiter. Schmusa, Matschschmusa. So was
haben wir doch schon mal ausprobiert. Der konnte den Hintergrund von Chico nicht richtig löschen.
Okay, das ist cool. Wenn das wirklich gut funktioniert, ist es Park. Naja, also von einem
weißen Hintergrund was löschen, kannst ja sogar mit Paint. Du müsstest, du müsstest was nehmen
in dem Hintergrund, dass er den Hintergrund auch ergänzt an der Stelle. Ja, das ist ja easy. Also
das, das kannst ja sogar mit Paint machen. Naja, ein bisschen was komplizierteres. Es gibt keine
[#Music still playing.
Wenn du in deinen Post-Topik gehst, werde ich die Vorteile von einem Morgen-Routine einstellen,
3 Varianten und das Kreativität-Level als optimal wählen.
Ich klick' an, für mich zu schreiben.
In an instant it's come up with 3 Caption-Ideas based on the post.
Ich glaube, mein Dark-Reader macht da die Seite kaputt.
Das ist was anderes, oder?
Das da ist das!
Alter, Mensch, sag mal!
Gut, dass wir unsere Fake-E-Mail-Adresse haben.
Der Image-Elarger ist am Start, ok.
Verify.
Äh, was will das jetzt?
Mitten im Alert, alles klar.
Äh...
Ok, ja, warum machen die dann Alert?
Was ist das?
Ok, der Image-Elarger.
Jetzt probieren wir das erstmal aus.
Also, Chico wird enlarged, Leute.
Chico wird auch vierfach enlarged.
Und dann erasen wir Chico mal und gucken, ob...
Processing, nee, Procressing, nicht Processing, Procressing.
Ok, und was war das andere?
Magic Eraser.
Draw Image here or click to upload.
Ok, wir, wir, wir, wir, wir, wir löschen, wir löschen Chico jetzt aus dem Bild.
Mh, gar nicht so schlecht.
Gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich mein, man, man, man sieht schon, dass hier irgendwas nicht so ganz richtig ist.
Aber, es ist schon ok, der versucht sogar, guck mal, der versucht sogar die Decke ein
bisschen nachzumachen.
Das ist, das ist gar nicht schlecht, doch, das ist gar nicht übel, das finde ich, finde
ich ok.
Das ist eine gute Seite, die Buchmarke, ich mir mal.
Ok, was macht der, was macht der, hier, Download, ok, Chico, Chico wurde, E-Mail, was, Download,
Chico wurde Enhanced, Leute, Alter, Chico ist mega Enhanced, man, 4K Chico, guck, man
konnte nur hier so, so, so weit zoomen und jetzt kann man hier so weit zoomen, Chico ist,
ist mega, mega Enhanced jetzt, das Fell wirkt auch deutlich detaillierter, guck mal, hier
oben und hier, man, man sieht schon, dass Chico an manchen Stellen nicht so original
mehr aussieht, aber es ist ziemlich gut, ziemlich gut Enhanced, Chico, muss man, muss man sagen,
es ist, es ist, es ist quasi KI Katze Enhanced, aber gar nicht, gar nicht schlecht, ja.
So, jetzt probieren wir das andere noch mal aus, die haben ja auch eine Bestätigung geschickt
gerade.
Ich brauche noch 10 Minuten länger, wer weiß, Verification, Code, Code, hier, Verify, was,
Enter your name, Kekl, was, piss dich Aldo, jetzt, seriously, die schicken mir erste Bestätigungs-Eben
und dann zu sagen, ich habe die falsche Domain, was ist das?
Meine IP ist gesperrt, okay, alles klar, dann nicht, dann ist es okay, erst mal gebannt,
erst mal gebannt.
Das ist gut, wenn das gute Titel, wenn das gute YouTube Titel erzeugt, dann benutze ich
das.
Titel ausdenken ist das schwerste an der ganzen Sache.
Okay, jetzt probieren wir aus, okay, jetzt probieren wir aus, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, jetzt probieren wir aus, Sekunde, talk to books, talk to books, say something, ich
weiß schon, was ich sage, Gachibas, go, was, ich glaube, der kommt mit Twitch Emotes nicht
so ganz klar, okay, was so, was schlägt er mir da vor, okay, was auch immer.
Okay, ich habe das hier, okay, ich habe das hier, okay, ich habe das hier, okay, was
ich sage, Gachibas, go, was, ich glaube, der kommt mit Twitch Emotes nicht so ganz klar
aus, okay, was ich sage, Gachibas, go, was, ich glaube, der kommt mit Twitch Emotes nicht
so ganz klar aus, okay, was ich sage, Gachibas, go, was, ich glaube, der kommt mit Twitch
Emotes nicht so ganz klar aus, okay, was ich sage, Gachibas, go, was, ich glaube, der kommt
mit Twitch Emotes nicht so ganz klar aus, okay, was ich sage, Gachibas, go, was, ich glaube,
Selber kompiliert nicht.
Okay, ich wollte gerade sagen, immerhin, weil mit zwei Gender ist ja heutzutage ist da Twitter direkt empört.
Ist das, ist das das Ding? Nee, das ist das Ding, wo der Google Typ, den sie jetzt gefeuert haben, gesagt haben, seine AI wäre self aware oder sowas.
Da ist doch irgend so ein verrückter bei Google rumgelaufen.
Okay, ich sag euch, ich sag euch was passieren wird. Sobald diese Sorte von Bots advanced genug sind, ich kann euch sagen, was die erste Branche sein wird, die damit richtig fett Geld macht. Und ihr wisst es genauso gut wie ich.
Und im Store? Der Shit hat einen Store? Da warste auch sonst.
Was ist das? Das ist cool. Geht das auch? Geht das auch für mich?
Das ist cool. Geht das auch? Geht das auch für Deutsch? Geht das auch auf Deutsch?
Scheint. Das finde ich cool, weil ich habe öfters mal so Dinge, wo ich mir denke, das kannst du eigentlich schon schöner schreiben.
Das finde ich gut.
Ja, waren aber coole Sachen dabei.
War coole Sachen dabei, muss ich sagen. Deswegen habe ich das letzte Mal dieses Video auch geguckt. Der hat tatsächlich coole Empfehlungen gehabt und es war diesmal auch nicht schlecht. Es ist selten, dass Titel ohne Videoinhalt irgendwie dann auch noch übereinstimmt und dann trotzdem passt.
Jetzt muss ich kurz was checken.
Okay, guck mal noch was an. Weiß nicht. Das fand ich wirklich interessant. Jetzt nicht. Was bildet der denn? Ah, der bildet wirklich was. Okay, das ist eine gute Idee.
Deswegen habe ich das vor ein paar Jahren auch gemacht. Aber für die meisten reicht wahrscheinlich fertiges Cynology nass oder sowas.
Das ist mir jetzt zu lang.
Alles klar.
Wisst ihr, die Sache ist halt die. Wenn ich einen Grill brauche, dann gehe ich auf Amazon und hole mir einfach einen Grill, anstatt da selbst irgendwas zu flexen und zu löten und so.
Ja, eher zu schweißen wahrscheinlich.
Also, but why?
Komplett unsinnig.
Nee, das sowas selbst zu bauen macht keinen Spaß.
Okay, das kommt mir jetzt an. Danach gehe ich futtern.
Danke für den Zap. Ein weiteres IKEA Rack. Es ist kein IKEA Rack. Es ist tatsächlich ein richtig echtes Rack, nur dass er oben drüber noch eine Platte von irgendeinem IKEA Ding drauf gepappt hat.
Er hat zumindest schon mal einen Mikrotik Router bzw. einen Mikrotik Switch. Das lässt mich vermuten, der weiß halbwegs, was er macht. Kein Unify Shit.
Ja, gut, werdet ihr das alles? Klar, das ist nicht ganz billig.
Beste Noctua-Kühler? Warum?
Gerade das ist kein deutscher. Ich glaube, das ist ein Finne oder so. Chat, ich weiß gar nicht, was ihr da wieder reinbringt. Ich glaube, das ist ein Finne. Oh nee, ich sag doch nichts. Das ist kein Finne, das ist ein deutscher.
Aber das hätte ich jetzt so gar nicht gehört. Das ist bessere Aussprache als 99% der Leute, die man so hört. Ich verstehe das gar nicht, warum die Leute immer so cringy sind, wenn Deutsche Englisch reden.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Ich habe schon mit einigen sowohl native-speaker als auch nicht native-speaker Englisch geredet und die haben alle keine Probleme mit deutschem Akzent. Die sagen halt im besten Fall so, ja man hört, du kommst aus Deutschland.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Und bei ihm ist es ja nur wirklich verdammt gut.
Ach so, dass er keine Klicks in Deutschland bekommt. Ja kann man so auch nicht sagen, der Bauer bekommt auch ziemlich viele Klicks für Videos in dieser Richtung.
Die Telekom ist wirklich, was das angeht, ziemlich international. Die hatten irgendwie einen Tscheche oder so, was das war. Sie hatten einen in Paris, sie hatten einen Deutschen, der in Tokio gearbeitet hat. Also die Telekom ist wirklich über die ganze Welt verteilt.
Die Telekom ist wirklich, was das angeht, ziemlich international. Die Telekom ist wirklich, was das angeht, ziemlich international. Die Telekom ist wirklich, was das angeht.
Ja das blöde bei solchen Gehäusen ist, dass sie keine Wechselrahmen haben, das heißt du musst immer aufschrauben und immer gucken und machen und das ist doof.
haben das heißt du musst immer aufschrauben und immer gucken und machen und es ist doof
selbst wie gesagt selbst wenn du kein hot swap machst es ist halt deutlich angenehmer eine festsplatte einfach raus zu ziehen aus zu
tauschen rein zu schieben anstatt da rum zu
schrauben und aufzumachen
12 2.5 inch drives
Es ist nicht wirklich für nass ausgestattet. z.B. um neue festsplatte oder neue festsplatte anzutauschen.
Also habe ich angefangen einen rackmounting enclosure zu bauen um meinen server zu bauen.
Ich habe nicht erwähnt, dass ich einen rackmounting case nicht will, weil sie laut sind und ich war falsch.
Wie du in diesem Video siehst, müssen Rack-Kontrollen nicht laut sein.
Die rein durch den formfaktor wird es natürlich nicht laut das ist durch die lüfter und das die meisten lüfter und lüfter
Regelungen in servan halb
wenn sie überhaupt regeln dann regeln sie doch
an punkten die man so nicht daheim haben will
Also ich habe ja schon mal erzählt also mein traum ist es ja schon immer mal gewesen es gibt jetzt die kisten gibt es jetzt in der form nicht
mehr wie schnell man es schaffen könnte ein playcenter
Also wie schnell könnte man ein playcenter fahren lassen wenn man das auf ordentliche rollen setzt
also was hier
So die alten die alten fetten
Kisten
Genau diese diese fetten diese fetten kisten ja also ich hätte ich würde zu gerne mal sehen mal angenommen
Du baust zwei schienen und machst irgendwie inlineskate rollen drunter oder so als irgendwas was wirklich gut rollt
Und du hättest nicht das problem mit dem strom kabel das würde ich gerne mal ausprobieren
dieses ding auf so auf oder auf bord stellen einfach nur auf ein bord was gut rollt und
Dann sowas habe ich nicht und dann ein netzteil rausziehen weil wenn du aus diesen dinger das netzteil rausgezogen hast ist
Einfach alles
Musst du nicht rausziehen setz halt irgendwas rausziehen wo das ding der meinung ist volle pulle wenn du 100 prozent
luft also wenn wenn das wenn die lüfter in diesen dinger auf 100 prozent drehen du musst dich wirklich dagegen lehnen also wenn du im
rechenzentrum bist im gang und stehst hinter so einem ding und da ist irgendwas kaputt drinne da drehen die dinger 100 prozent lüfter hoch so sicher ist sicher
Und du musst wenn du dich dann dahinter kniest oder oder so in die hocke gehst hinter dem ding dass du rankommst du musst dich wirklich
nach vorne lehnen
so dass du
Dass du quasi nicht um kippst
Und nicht zu wenig
Und ich fand auch sehr schnell, dass sie alle sehr teuer sind
Ja sie sind sehr teuer, einfach ebay
Ich kann ich kann auch leider bei ebay klein anzeigen nix kaufen weil ebay klein anzeigen
Er der meinung ist mein nicht vorhandener account wurde gesperrt
Listen an ebay
Welche vorteil haben die plates eigentlich jetzt heutzutage weiß ich nicht ob man sowas noch verwenden würde du hast halt damals relativ viel
server unterbekommen in
Wenig wenig platz
Ja man kann da auch bestimmt schön esx drauf laufen lassen klar warum nicht
Also platz technisch dürfte das eigentlich immer noch unschlagbar sein aber heute kriegst du halt fette kisten auch mit
Massig ram und kern das ist halt die sache bei den placentern war immer ein bisschen das problem mit ram bestückung
Also ich meine du kriegst die aber die sind schweine teuer wir hatten wir hatten die standard bestückung damals war bei uns schon
96 gig ram und ihr könnt euch vorstellen das ist paar jährchen her
Ja 96 gig ram also so ein plate kostet es ungefähr was was damals so der 0815 klein wagen gekostet hat
also irgendwie keine ahnung 18.000 euro oder so
mit der ausstattung das war schon nicht ohne
über micro sc 833 enclosure für
$119 it came with eight hot soap hard drive base one internal 3.5 inch bay and a power supply
The only caveat is that it didn't come with any rails so I had to buy that myself with the main
Ja gibt es ja zum glück universelle solverschienen itself so during my extensive research aka five minutes in amazon
I found this samsung 12 unit rack for musical equipment
I looked at the price said hmm
I guess I could afford that and added it to my wish list what I did not take into account is the fact that this
Rack is only 46 centimeter deep and most server enclosures including the super micro sc
Das war bei mir auch echt problematisch
Es ist ja hier ist nicht was gibt es in die sonst noch schön
Ja ja max ist gut ihr seht hier ist nicht viel platz drin bei mir in diesem kleinen technikraum
Und der mittlerweile auch nicht mehr so aussieht aber ihr seht also ich habe auch ein rack was keine volle volle tiefe hat
Weil der kram nicht reinpasst in den raum
DC 833 case are at least 65 centimeters deep after some further research
Ja das ist nicht schlimm die gucken dann hinten raus
je nachdem was man für leisten hat geht das auch aber
Bei mir hätte es halt gar nicht in den in den
Raum gepasst
Das 12-jährige rack von startech
Bei 277 euro war es zweimal mehr teuer als der samsung rack
Aber er ist gebaut wie ein tank und hat sich mit unterschiedlichen Depthsettings ausgestattet
The reason why i went with an open rack design is because full blown rack closets are actually even more expensive
Das stimmt, das ist teuer
385 euros and this one is 350
Unsinnig teuer ich verstehe gar nicht warum die dinger so teuer sind
Es ist nicht so als ist da irgendwie so krasseste technik aller zeiten drin und die hochwertigsten materiale in aller zeit nicht
Ich denke es ist einfach teuer weil es
diese Sorte
Gerät ist oder ist ja kein gerät weil es weil es diese diese sorte
produkt ist
Pater, danke für den sub
Just the depth and in general an open rack would just be more convenient to work on and provide better airflow
Ja deswegen habe ich auch ein open rack
Was kind of like building ikea furniture, but easier it came with pretty easy instructions and the whole process took me around 40 minutes
Meins hat keine reifen
Ich hätte jeder dran machen können wollte ich damals aber nicht
Taking care of let's build our server first. I was so hin und her schieben
It arrived condition and still had all the original parts including the fans and the power supply so that had to be fixed
There's nothing wrong with the stock fans installed in red like this one
However, you have to keep in mind that those service are made to be used in data centers where the most important things are static pressure
Airflow and ensuring that the components are running as cool as possible same goes to the power supply
I'm sure that there's gonna be a lot of angry people in the comments absolutely
furious at me for removing the super micro power supply the pinnacle of industrial server hardware and replacing it with a measly corsair sf
450 but once again the power supply that this case came with had a loud fan
And it only had 80 plus ich wollte gerade sagen
Nachdem man das ding wahrscheinlich auch nicht großartig auslasten wird ist ein kleineres netzteil mit gutem wirkungsgrad sicherlich besser
weil viele netzteile also auch die auch die
platinium ultra
Dingsbums effizient netzteile die sind meistens auch nicht so toll wenn das irgendwie sagen wir keine ahnung das ist ein
800 watt netzteil und ein server braucht 20
So richtig gut sind die meistens nur wenn sie zumindest ein bisschen ausgelastet sind
Whereas the fan in my corsair sf 450 only ramps up on their heavy load and the power supply has 80 platinum rating
Which will definitely help with the power efficiency
I won't be using this server in a data center it will be standing right next to my desk and because of that low noise
And power efficiency are much more important to me
So I'll find the fans and the fans and the fan brackets then it was time to take the server out of the old case
Then it was time to take the server out of the old case not much to say here this case
Er hat zwar am anfang gesagt ich mein ich habe mal system integrator gelernt ja es soll nicht zugucken aber das ist doch alles vollkommen in ordnung was
Was meint ihr wieder teilweise auch im profi umfeld
Improvisiert wird bei manchen sachen jetzt weniger jetzt weniger bei irgendwelchen schienen und surfern im rack
Ja, aber da gibt es auch teilweise ganz haarsträumende workarounds die schon gesehen habe gerade in technik in etagen technik räumen alter
Da habe ich schon gesehen switche die hochkant hingen an stellen wo nichts hängen hängen sollte und so
Just to work in but I pretty much know what inside out at this point
I connected the sata cables to the backplane as well as my PCIe devices the 10 gig network card and the ssd adapter
Riesen guckt euch das war eine
riesen
Surfergehäuse und dann am ende ist das so ein bord drin
Das ist die adapter. Ich benutze diese PCIe bifurcating riser, was
Ein PCIe x16 Slot in zwei Slots x8 und x4 und es gibt auch eine
Okay, cool cool für die fans. Ich benutze drei noctua und f8 12 x 25 fans
Es gab keine montagehäuser für 120 mm fans in dem Fall, also nutze ich die einzige richtige Weise um Fans in der industriellen Surferklaufe zu fixieren
Zip ties
Don't say I didn't warn you. Aber das funktioniert dieses mit diesen karten das funktioniert glaube ich nur wenn das bord das auch
unterstützt oder wenn die irgendwie
Ich weiß wenn du pech hast geht das nicht
Dieses aufsplitten von PCIe express ich glaube das muss das bord können oder die müssen irgendwie die
PCIe express switches passend
Designed haben also das können nicht alle boards ich weiß nicht genau woran es liegt ob es ein bord kann oder nicht aber ich weiß kann nicht
Jedes bord weil du kannst nicht einfach in PCIe express 16 slot nehmen standardmäßig haben die ja beispielsweise dann auch
die die
die strombelegung von den pins
Wo du nicht einfach hinten was abgreifen kann also ich kann es euch nicht genau sagen woran es liegt ich weiß nur dass es boards gibt
Und wo das wo das nicht gescheit funktioniert spin freely because of this metal post das geht nicht in jede borde
Und da wir gehen alle drei fans sind
sicher zu dem Fall und spin freilich
Einmal wieder würde ich das nicht tun, wenn du einen Server für irgendeinen seriösen, mission-kritischen Applikation
Datacenter use oder alles so, warum ich mit diesem janky fan setup und einem sfx power supply
Und so passt alles zusammen
Ich bin aber ein sehr finde ich ein sehr stylisches
Technik eck hier weil die Farbe von der wand und vom stuhl und so passt alles zusammen
Nicht in einem datacenter
Auch wenn ich die komponenten biete habe ich eine wissenschaftliche Wahl gemacht, mit niedriger kräftigkeit, niedriger kräftiges und niedriger kräftiges
Und das ist so ein melanox ding ja die gibt's relativ günstig bei ebay
Und von denen habe ich auch. Drei stück hier und
Don't worry i did a lot of testing and monitoring afterwards to make sure that
Abluft ist in dem fall gar nicht so wild ich denke mal. Ihr hast doch gesehen das ist ein riesen gehäuse massig lüfter
Und ein ganz kleines board was wahrscheinlich auch noch ziemlich lau power ist ich glaube nicht dass es da viel zum abtransportieren gibt
cool
Finally shout out to this ridiculous proprietary front panel connector. I didn't have any mail
So I just got the other end completely and used a multimeter and this game that I found on the internet to map the connections
One thing that definitely got the professional enterprise makeover that it deserved or the hard drives
I initially started off with shocked smr drives from wd my book and ran merger fast
Ich bin mal gespannt ob es hinbekommen hat weil das ist tatsächlich nicht so easy
Und teilweise gar nicht möglich ob er falls falls das board
Festplatten fehler leds hat ob er die bekommen angeschlossen bekommen hat das ist nicht so easy
Die die boards haben ja vorne wechselrahmen also nicht die boards die die die gehäuse die haben ja vorne wechselrahmen für festplatten
Und die guten gehäuse haben in diesen wechselrahmen nicht nur aktivitätsanzeigen für die festplatten sondern auch fehleranzeigen für die festplatten dass du weißt
Welche festplatte kaputt ist und das kommunizieren mit diesem frontpanel für diese fehler leds ist
Absoluter steinzeit shit und die meisten boards haben da gar keinen anschluss für drauf
Und selbst wenn ich die frage ob das dein frontpanel unterstützt
Hier unten müssten eigentlich ich vermute aktivitäts led und error led
All the components that I installed...
Nö, Sassplatten braucht man nicht, das ist eh overrated.
First off, I got this nice wooden top from a hardware store and put it on top of the rack
to kind of hide my poor cable management.
And as an added bonus, I can actually put stuff on it.
So the power strip is probably one of the easiest ones of the bunch.
There are a lot of rack-mountable power strips for sale and I went with this one, mostly
because it had the power plugs on the rear.
I installed it on top of the rack, as you can see, and it was pretty much it.
The only annoying thing is that the European power plugs are oriented diagonally and a
lot of devices have those massive power bricks.
Because of that, one power brick can basically block three ports, including the two that
are adjacent to it, which is not ideal.
I'm definitely going to invest into an actual UPS at some point in the future, but for now
this power strip has been doing its job pretty well.
What you could also do is actually put in a cheap remote-switchable power plug strip.
Some kind of Chinese thing that you can flash.
Then you have four or five power plugs, and theoretically even USB, which you can switch
on and off remotely.
It doesn't look very enterprise-y, but it's like a yoke if it's in the rack somewhere
back there.
On the other hand, I personally don't have any devices that don't have any front-facing
ethernet ports, such as my NAS or the CECM4 router board, so I got this 16-port patch
panel from D-Lock.
I didn't actually know that you needed a special tool to punch in the wires in the patch panel,
and I just used a flathead screwdriver and some cutters.
Don't do it though, just...
Die bessere Variante ist eh das, wo du das auflegst und dann zusammendrückst.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich persönlich verwende keinerlei Patch-Panel in meinem... Ja, genau,
ich hab nur ein Keystore-Patch-Panel.
Richtig.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich hab nämlich kein Patch-Panel zum Auflegen, sondern ich
benutze einfach... Kabel.
Kabel mit AIO45-Steckern.
Und an der Sache oben hab ich ein Keystone-Panel, also da könnte ich theoretisch sogar eigene
Stecker dran machen.
Per Keystone-Jack und das rein.
Buy the tool.
Or better yet, buy a Keystone-Patch-Panel.
They're usually on the expensive side, but trust me, it's worth it.
Next up, the switch.
I was using a TP-Link and Managed-PoE-Switch and this Microtech 4-port SFP-Plus-Switch for
my 10-gig connectivity.
But since I wanted an untagged VLANs, I needed something smarter than that.
I decided to go with this Microtech CRS326... Ja, endlich, endlich mal einer den gescheiten
Switch hat, Alter.
Dieser ganze UniFi-Crap, den er immer auf YouTube empfohlen wird.
Microtech, Leute, ich sag's euch, beste, beste... Was ist denn das, ein CRS... Das
sind die mit 2x 10-g und 24 1-g... Ja, endlich, das ist ein guter Switch.
Preis-Leistungs-mäßig ist das Ding übrigens auch ziemlich gut.
Den gibt's in der CSS-Variante, in der CRS-Variante.
Der Unterschied ist, das hier ist mit Switch OS und das hier ist mit Router OS, nimmt sich
preislich ein bisschen was.
Ich würde euch tatsächlich den empfehlen mit Router OS.
Hier, guck mal, die Switch OS-Variante kostet 170 Euro und die andere... Na, ich bin leider
immer noch nicht gesponsort von Microtech und die andere kostet 210, das lohnt sich
wirklich.
Also, wenn ihr einen Switch sucht, Preis-Leistungs-mäßig werdet ihr nichts besseres finden in diesem
Preissegment mit den Features und den passenden Anschlüssen, also das ist wirklich nicht
übel.
Es gibt nur noch bessere Preis-Leistungs-technisch, allerdings dann mit nicht 24 Ports... 24 Ports
1-g.
Die haben sogar mittlerweile schon 25- und 40-g-Dinger halbwegs erschwinglich.
Genau.
Und gerne auch... Was würdet ihr auf 2,5-g upgraden eigentlich, reicht mir eigentlich?
Na ja, kommt drauf an.
Wenn du jetzt einen neuen Rechner hast, wo das Mainboard 2,5-g kann, dann würde ich
schon irgendwie gucken, aber du brauchst halt auch was auf der Gegenseite, wo es irgendwie
Sinn macht.
Also, wenn du jetzt... Was weiß ich, wenn du nur YouTube-Videos guckst oder so, das
ist egal.
Also, wenn du irgendwie nass hast, wo du Sachen überträgst, was dann auch mit 10 oder 2,5
oder 5 angebunden ist, dann schon, aber einfach nur 2,5 zu haben, weil die Netzwerkkarte 2,5
kann, macht keinen Sinn.
Für deinen Internetanschluss brauchst du es nicht.
Selbst wenn du Glasfaserkram hast, mehr als 1 Gigabit gibt es da nicht und du musst da
auch erstmal irgendwas finden, was mit dir der Geschwindigkeit kommunizieren will.
Ne, also, eben würde ich es nicht unbedingt machen.
Das Schöne ist, das Gute ist, wenn du einen 10 Gigabit-Switch hast, so wie er, dann kannst
du in diesem Port auch Module machen mit 2,5 und 5G, wenn du welche findest, aber prinzipiell
geht das.
Aber es macht eh keinen Sinn, weil, ganz im Ernst, wenn du einen 10G-Switch hast, dann
kannst du dir einfach auf Ebay so eine Mellanox-Karte kaufen, ich glaube, so eine hatte hier auch
am Anfang gezeigt, diese Low-Profile-Mellanox-Karten, das kostet dann 30 Euro und baust das einkaufst
dir ein Direct-Attached-Kabel, das ist quasi ein SFP-Plus-Modul auf beiden Seiten mit Kupferkabel
dazwischen, das geht, glaube ich, bis zu 7 Meter oder so passiv und das reicht ja in
der Regel vom Switch zu deinem Rechner.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die bessere Variante.
Wenn du das Gerät eher als Switch benutzt, ist Switch OS besser, das stimmt schon irgendwo,
gerade weil Router OS die WLAN-Config richtig abfuck ist.
Das stimmt schon, wenn ich mir das angucke, ist das glaube ich auch sogar Switch OS, was
er hat, ach du bist, ach cool, moin, zu was Zufall hier, ja, also ich habe von Mikrotik
einen, wie heißt das Ding hier stehen, hatte ich mir extra für dieses, wo ich manchmal
Zeug bastel und die Kamera drüber hängen kaufte, ich habe hier einen CSS 610, der hat
auch 2x 10G und 8 1G und da ist auch Switch OS drauf, man kommt damit klar, das coole
an Router OS ist halt wirklich, du kannst alles machen, was die meisten Leute nicht
machen wollen, aber angefangen von simplen Firewall-Regeln, du kannst dann DNS drüber
machen, du kannst dann DHCP, du kannst alles drüber machen, aber auf der anderen Seite
ist Router OS halt wirklich abfuck in der Konfig, also gerade die WLAN-Config, die WLAN-Config
in Router OS ist, du kannst auf 3 Varianten kannst du WLANs konfigurieren und die können
dir bei Mikrotik selbst nicht sagen, welche Variante jetzt eigentlich die beste ist.
The OS Web Interface is also super nice and simple, which is great, can't say the same
about Router OS unfortunately.
Jetzt wenn du hier im Stream bist, muss ich mich mal fragen, hast du jetzt zufällig bei
Twitch durchgeguckt und hast gesehen wir haben da ein Video auf oder wie bist du jetzt hergekommen?
Stimmt, mit CLI ist nichts, stimmt, Switch OS geht nur über einen Browser glaube ich.
Ach aus dem Discord hat es gesagt, witzig, wisst ihr mal wie schnell sich das verbreitet
hier?
Mag ich nicht, ja also erstens sind die Dinger teuer und ich muss mich ja outen an der Stelle,
ich hab in meinem Rack auch einen ES16XG von Ubiquiti, damals noch für 5 und Alter warum
nicht?
Mittlerweile sind sogar 5 Jahre alte Router Switches teurer geworden, das ist aber kein
UniFi Switch, das ist halt ein 12 Port 10G, 4 Port 10G Switch, das war zu Zeiten wo ich
gedacht hab, ich mach hier richtig krass das 10G Netzwerk und im Endeffekt, was ist es
heute?
Eine Kiste hat 10G und mein Desktop hat 10G, sonst hat nichts 10G, aber Hauptsache ein
12, ein 16 Port 10Gigabit Switch gekauft damals, echt, die gleichen Kabel hab ich glaub ich
bei Amazon gekauft, ach witzig, die gleichen Kabel hab ich auch gekauft nur in weiß, Post
Image und das hier mit dem, ach nee da sieht, doch guck mal das ist genau das gleiche für
den Access Point an der Decke, das sind genau die gleichen Kabel nur in weiß, man sieht
jetzt die Stecker nicht und die hab ich auch gekauft einzig allein aus dem Grund weil die
so dünn waren, nee Flachbandkabel mag man vielleicht nehmen wenn man irgendwie durchs
Fenster muss oder so, aber ansonsten ist eh das Problem, du musst halt mit dem Stecker
durch, ist das da oben, ist das Kameraverlängerung, ist die Kameraverlängerung hier, ist das
Kameraverlängerung, sieht ein bisschen aus wie dieses Kameraverlängerungsboard, was sagst
du zu diesem Switch, ich muss mal gucken, ach so, ich dachte es ist die Kamera, was sagst
du dazu, QNAP, 2,5G Smart Switch, ok es sind 2x 10G und 8x 2,5, finde ich ist ein ziemlich
guter, rein von der Bestückung her, ein ziemlich guter Switch für den Schreibtisch, du machst
ein Uplink, nennen wir es mal Uplink, du machst das an deinen Rec Switch mit 10Gb und dann
kannst du deine ganzen Geräte am Schreibtisch mit 2,5 anschließen, die das unterstützen,
das klingt erstmal nach einem richtig guten Schreibtisch Switch, natürlich die Frage
was der Kram kostet, ok es hat einen Lüfter, aktiv gekühlt ist für den Schreibtisch schon
mal wahrscheinlich nicht so geil und ja Preis würde ich sagen geht in Ordnung, ich weiß
halt nicht wie man die QNAP Switches, was ist denn das da hinten, what the fuck, hä,
warum ist da so eine grüne Ecke hinten, was, ist das für den Style Faktor oder, was soll
das sein, ach nee, hä, what, was bin ich sehend hier, hä, ist das Diebstahlschutz
oder, Leute ich hab legit keine Ahnung was das für ein Ding da hinten ist, Netzteil,
ist das Netz, das ist der Stromstecker, Ufo-Landeplatz, ja gut keine Ahnung, da hab ich schon schönere
Anschlüsse für Stromstecker gesehen, hm, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
absolut, ok, ok.
Es sieht trotzdem richtig ordentlich aus.
Was macht ihr eigentlich immer alle mit Plex? Ich hab kein Plex.
Also ich persönlich sehe den Einsatzzweck für Plex nicht so wirklich,
weil ich brauche ein bisschen was entspannenderes.
Plex ist halt, wenn man riesen Filmesammlung hat oder sowas.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich gucke fast nur Filme über Amazon oder Netflix oder YouTube.
Also Filme nicht, aber ich gucke fast nur Streams.
Ich gucke Filme über Netflix, Amazon und Streams über Twitch und YouTube.
Also ich hab überhaupt kein Anwendungsgebiet für Plex.
Der einzige Grund, den ich mir vorstellen könnte, wozu man einen Plex-Server verwendet, ist sowas.
Oder aber wenn man das dann im Zweifelsfall auch noch sharet mit irgendwelchen anderen Plex-Instanzen.
Oder wenn man mega Upload 2.0 machen will.
Aber ansonsten, weiß nicht.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich habe auf der Arbeit ein paar Kollegen, von denen weiß ich es, die haben Serien.
Der eine hat die Serien auch über irgendwelche Usenet-Dinger sich gezogen.
Der hat irgendwie 350 Folgen von irgendwelchen Serien, die er sich dann ab und zu anguckt mit einem Plex-Server.
Das verstehe ich.
Also ich bei meinem Anwendungsprofil brauche kein Plex-Server.
Also ich verstehe auch nicht, warum so viele Leute Plex-Server haben.
Doch wohl繼續 voll Pegel machen.
Zuerst ging es aber wirklich um einen Plex-Server.
Katy Shihrer ist是不是 dann variationsierter als eine Preisionreinigung?
Dann hätte er gerne einen Mixer dafür, den frischen Schu body zu nominationen.
Die Bücher wurden stark oder immer steel und immerPC problems.
Krator zuguckt also ich habe den kram mal irgendwann gelernt 2007
Also viel besser ganz wahrscheinlich nach heimlich machen
Und was ich ja cool finde ist dass die farbe von deinem sitzpolster zur wandfarbe passt also das ist ja das ist
Das ist ja wirklich schon
Next-level das ist ja nicht nur welche leute die sich rgb machen und das dann passend machen das passt einfach von der standardfarbe ja schon
Und das ist so ein cooles bild kann man nichts sagen
Aber leute ich kann doch nicht mal sagen mikrotik switcher mikrotik router beste
Ja ich kann es verstehen dass es leute gibt die sagen hey ich habe jede menge unify access points ich will auch in unify
Sonst wie switch haben und ist alles über eine oberfläche managen
ja
Verstehe ich verstehe ich
Aber ich habe mein unify zeug komplett rausgeschmissen sowohl die access points
Ne
Wollte sagen sowohl die wechsel sowohl die access points als auch aber ich hatte ja nie was anderes
Ich habe den edge switch der bleibt drinne aber die unify dinger habe ich alle rausgeschmissen
Es hat mich jemand vorhin gefragt ob ich erfahrungen mit sysco meraki mekari oder irgendwas habe ich weiß was das ist das ist den ihr
cloud gestütztes wlan zeug habe ich aber keine erfahrungen mit
Du machst es dann so wie dieser eine kerl wo wir wo wir schon ich habe vergessen was es für ein channel war wir haben noch mal
von von von
irgendeinem typ auf youtube videos geguckt der daheim irgendwie drei kopanete cluster hatte und sowas wo ich mir auch gedacht habe warum
warum
Technotip genau warum weshalb warum macht man sowas
Ne ne nicht den technotip war das genau wo ich auch gedacht hat der typ übertreibt es aber mal richtig massiv
Der braucht quasi einen vollzeit job um sich sein heim um sich um sein heim setup zu kümmern ich bin mittlerweile
der meinung
Gerade für daheim ich mein nachdem ich acht stunden am tach ok ich mache es nur vier tage die woche aber acht stunden am tach mich mit so
Krempel auf der arbeit auseinandersetzen will ich habe kein bock
mich auch noch mal stunden mit meinem heim setup auseinanderzusetzen der kram der muss funktionieren
Ja ab und zu muss man mal ein paar stunden rein stecken den kram updaten vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen was ausprobieren aber zum großteil muss
Der kram einfach funktionieren ich habe keinen bock mich daheim um kubernetes cluster zu kümmern
Android habe ich auch mittlerweile ich war ich war die ganze zeit auch immer richtiger verfechter von
Ubuntu server oder demian server alles alles selbst gemacht
Aber gerade im heimbereich hat so ein easy webgui schon seine vorteile
Zumal bei Android das coole ist dass du auch addons hast und teilweise addons die seit fünf sechs jahren in entwicklung sind und
Supported werden wo man sich auch keine gedanken machen muss dass die morgen weg sind
Ja hauptsache paar buzzwords reinhauen daheim
Also ich bin ja der meinung blockchain und ei integration lösen alle probleme bei mir daheim
Gibt es immer schief ein video wo du da hatte der zertifikat für den lokalen ja mehrfach mehrere videos haben wir da
Eine gibt gibt ich muss mal gucken ich weiß nicht was für schief wir haben ein paar streams gemacht mit zertifikaten
Passwort selbst lokale letzten kripp zertifikate deck
docker gibt
Ja das haben wir mal gemacht und dann haben wir was mit load balancer gemacht also wir haben mehrfach schon lokale
Also wir haben mehrfach schon lokale zertifikate ausgestellt von der idee her ist es auch einfach lokale zertifikate zu machen
Du brauchst eine domain da kommst du nicht drumherum
Also da kannst du kannst du keine letzten kripp zertifikate ausstellen lassen für irgendwie lokale domain die es nur bei dir gibt du brauchst eine
Du brauchst eine gültige domain du kannst aber die billigste domain der billigen kaufen du kaufst irgendwie eine hier
Kalimero 09
Punkt
An oder so irgendwelche domains die sonst keine handel kostet sich dann 120 im jahr
120 im jahr
Und dann hast du eine domain und das alles was du dann machen musst ist
Du stellst bei deinem domain registrar
Wenn er das nicht kann deine
Muss ich anders anfangen du machst das einfach bei einem domain registrar
Wo das ordentlich funktioniert mit dns api und dann nimmst du zertbot oder irgendwie in den reverse proxy der das kann
Und lässt dir über dns challenge
Letzten kripp zertifikate ausstellen du kannst es auch mit dac dns machen ja das funktioniert auch
Da kriegst du auch gültig also du brauchst ok dass du brauchst eine gültige
Externe domain oder sub domain also das muss irgendwas sein was aus dem internet aus auflösbar ist
Dac dns ist auch vollkommen ok ok du brauchst irgendeine domain die auflösbar ist aus dem internet
Wo man, wo man echte zusätzliche
Name also wo man echte nameserver abfragen kann wo du dann deine txt records hinterlegen kannst
Ja die kenne ich von denen haben wir auch schon ein paar videos geguckt da waren schon paar echt
Cringy gesachen dabei zum beispiel dieses dieses windows tuning kit wo ich mir auch gedacht habe wer zum teufel
Interessiert installiert sich sowas ansonsten finde ich die aber ganz cool. Das ist der der mich immer an mein zahnarzt erinnert
Also glaube ich glaube ich zumindest das ist das ist der der aussicht wie mein zahnarzt aber nicht mein zahnarzt ist
Ja genau genau der sieht aus wie mein zahnarzt das ist aber nicht mein zahnarzt
Aber auch schon ein paar sachen geguckt
Ja dac dns geht auch ist wunderbar wie gesagt du brauchst auf jeden fall
Du musst an einen lokalen alpies nicht eintragen das ist ja der witz an dns challenges
Also was du machen musst ist du brauchst eine domain die
über
Auto wie auf deutsch
Autoritative nameserver verfügt
Moment wie heißt das auf deutsch richtig
Chat helft mir war also brauchst auf jeden fall eine domain
Die man abfragen kann wo dann als antwort zurückkommt diese nameserver sind dafür zuständig
Autoritativ
Und dann musst du dns challenge machen mit let's encrypt du musst deine server nicht auflösbar haben über diese über diese ip
Du musst
Txc records für die dns challenge dahinter hinterlegen und wenn du dann die server lokal auflösbar haben willst trägst du es bei dir lokal im router
Ein du musst das nicht externe in also du musst jetzt nicht in dein dns eintragen
XYZ punkt calimero 09 punkt fun hat
1921 680 punkt eins oder so das brauchst du nichts kannst du in deinem router machen und gut ist also diese kisten die du
Zertifikate ausstellen muss die müssen nicht auflösbar sein aus dem internet
Du musst
nur den dns server haben der txt records über die api eintrag ein eintragen kann also
Entweder machst du deine domains über cloudflare oder du lässt halt den server umbiegen auf cloudflare haben wir schon gemacht muss man
Mal schief gucken es ist wenn man es mal gemacht hat ist wirklich nicht schwierig
Ja
Leute drei stunden und ich hoffe ihr seid wach ich habe hunger ich gehe jetzt was futtern
Wir sehen uns
Vielleicht machen wir heute mittag noch ein bisschen weiter mit terraform und cloud geschichten
Mal gucken vielleicht auch nicht
Ich habe schon oft genug versprochen ich mache mittags-sommer stream und bin an dich angekommen
Gucken wir mal
Aber jetzt ja ihr seht ja das heißt wenn ihr noch nicht gefolgt habt dann folgen jetzt am besten kriegt ihr mit wenn ich wieder online bin
Und wir sehen uns macht es gut bis denn zu